Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Once moved on, under Twitch chat, from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made your feet.
Keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes, typing dance games, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Life was easy at the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made your feet.
Keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitch emotes, still hear his bark in the morning hour.
He calls me, his doggy mode reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I'm yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made your feet.
Auf geht's.
Wobei, die hat damit gar nichts zu tun, aber irgendwie passt es gerade.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Wobei, dass die anderen nicht so gut wegkommen, den haben wir auch noch.
Und vielleicht sollte ich die Emotes ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Excellent.
So.
Moment, die Emotes sind auf der falschen Seite.
Hackermans.
Emotes müssen da hin, auch wenn da der Chat ist, und dann kommen sie weg.
Excellent.
So.
Ja, was wird uns da denn empfohlen?
Das ist ja der Klassiker-Clip schlechthin.
Das ist ja der OG.
Der Original-Clip, der Klassiker schlechthin.
Wenn man sich überlegt, das ist von 2011.
2011 haben noch irgendwelche komischen Trickshots auf, äh...
Und wie hieß die Map?
Highrise war das, oder?
Noch irgendjemand interessiert.
Tribun und elf Monate.
Oh, huge sub.
Ein, ein Monat vor...
Ah, trotzdem.
Kurz was dringen.
Exquisite.
Kamillentee.
Ah, die Wii Shop Musik.
Okay, ich muss jetzt auf Amazon.
So was kaufen.
Instant.
Die Wii Shop Musik, die regt einen echt zum Einkaufen an.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen, was mir gerade einfällt.
Ich hab nie in einem Wii Shop was gekauft.
Ich fand nur die Wii Shop Musik gut.
Weil irgendwann hab ich mir gedacht, okay.
Nintendo schaltet den Kram garantiert eh ab.
Und was hat Nintendo gemacht?
Den Kram abgeschaltet.
Aber ist ja klar, ich mein, die Wii ist ja alt.
Und, äh, dann hab ich im Internet geguckt.
Also, how to...
äh, äh, Flash oder how to, was weiß ich, Homebrew Wii, hab ich festgestellt.
Das ist total einfach.
Man muss einfach nur manipulierte SD-Karte reinmachen und easy.
Wobei die ersten Wii-Hacks mit, mit, äh, Twilight Princess waren wirklich abenteuerlich.
Mit dem Pferdenamen und dass man rückwärts mit diesem NPC reden musste und so.
Also, wir haben eine, äh, Moment, das kennen wir doch schon.
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Ich mein, irgendwann ist ja auch mal gut.
Die, ich sag ja nicht, dass es unwichtig ist, aber, ich mein, als gäb's da jetzt jeden Tag so ultrakrasses neues Zeug zu vermelden,
dass jeder Nachrichtensender irgendwelche Videos zu bringen kann.
Da gibt's doch jetzt, ich mein, es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt täglich wahnsinnig neue Erkenntnisse, die für die Allgemeinheit relevant wären, rauskommen.
Nein, sie können uns, also, YouTube kann mich da jetzt auch mal wieder mit in Ruhe lassen, äh.
Dual-Wheeled M249.
Ah, ja, excellent, YouTube.
Linux-Gaming.
Ja, vieles funktioniert halt einfach nicht.
Ich hab mir ja schon öfters mal den Hass zugezogen, äh, also quasi ex-, äh, übertriebener Linux-Fanboy ist immer, wenn ich sag, dass es nicht funktioniert mit Spielen richtig unter Linux.
Äh, doch, doch, das geht, du musst ja nur 75.000 Einstellungen machen, dann hast du Glück, dass es vielleicht trotzdem irgendwie gerade so läuft.
Ja, gut, mein, vieles läuft tatsächlich mittlerweile, aber wenn man einfach nur einschalten will, spielen will, ist halt Linux nach wie vor nix.
Es sei denn, die Hersteller kommen.
Ich will jetzt einfach mal auf die glorreiche Idee und sagen, oh, Linux-Support.
Okay, ich will jetzt aber nicht dem Typ die ganze Zeit zukommen.
Wobei, das können wir doch mal gucken.
Das ist ja eine Playlist, die sich mit der Lautstärke wieder nicht, äh, entscheiden kann.
Was ist das?
Speedrunners React, oh, das ist, das können wir tatsächlich gucken.
Das ist Speedrunners React, okay.
Excellent.
Das kriegen wir heute eh nicht alles geguckt.
Moment.
Nee, nee, Mensch, wir fangen mal vorne an, oder?
Also.
Also, wenn ihr irgendwelche Videos habt, die ihr euch unbedingt angucken müsst, könnt ihr euch, äh, Bescheid sagen.
Ich hab, ich hab zwar noch einige Sachen übrig.
Übrigens, ich muss, ich muss euch was erzählen, ja.
Ähm.
Muss ich auch so ein bisschen, äh, anonymisieren, ja.
Und zwar.
Ah.
Ja, ähm.
Genau, also, stimmt, also, weil, weil, weiß ich, weil, genau, jetzt, jetzt, äh, muss ich mal kurz, äh, in mich gehen, genau.
Also, was ich euch erzählen wollte, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, äh, bei uns auf der Arbeit hatten wir ein bisschen Probleme mit Windows-Viren in letzter Zeit.
Also, also, also, rein mit Windows-Viren.
Also, wie man generell Probleme hat, ja.
Und, ähm, es wurden auch ein paar Sachen verschlüsselt und sowas.
Und, ach, voll für den Arsch, ja.
Zumindest, jetzt ist man auf die chlorreiche Idee gekommen.
Jetzt, nachdem man den ganzen Kram wieder bereinigt hat, ist man auf die chlorreiche Idee gekommen.
Oder, äh, Chat, überlegt mal, was könnte man machen, wenn man Windows-Viren hat, die File-Server verschlüsseln, es sind nur Windows-Systeme betroffen und, äh, die Linux-Systeme funktionieren wunderbar und gab keine Probleme mit.
Was, was, was könnte man, was könnte man machen?
Umsteigen, das ist eine, das ist eine gute Idee, ja, das könnte, das könnte man machen, ja, das wäre eine gute Idee.
Oder, oder, ihr wisst, das ist, äh, äh, wie, äh, Antivirus-Zeug ist, ist, ist schon installiert, ja.
Aber, okay, manche Sachen können die auch nix machen.
So, aber ihr wisst, es ist super krasses Business.
Was macht man bei uns auf der Arbeit?
Man ersetzt bestehende Linux-Systeme jetzt durch Windows.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Die sind, ha, ha, ha, ha, die sind auf die chlorreiche Idee gekommen.
Und haben gesagt, ähm.
Die Windows-Systeme, die Probleme hatten, die haben sie jetzt ja bereinigt.
Und jetzt haben sie sich von Microsoft irgendwelche Berater geholt.
Die haben ihnen gesagt, ähm, vermute ich mal, dass das so gewesen ist.
Äh, die haben ihnen irgendwie jetzt gesagt, ähm, ja, wir empfehlen, äh, komplette Windows-Umgebung.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und jetzt wollen sie die, die Kisten, die paar Linux-Kisten, die nicht betroffen waren, äh, wollen sie jetzt durch Windows ersetzen.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die kann ich, also wir haben danach noch jede Menge andere Linux-Kisten, ne.
Also es ist nicht so, als, als wenn die jetzt, als wenn die jetzt einfach weg.
Also es geht, es geht nur um ein paar.
Es geht nur um ein paar, die halt mehr oder weniger neben denen standen, die betroffen waren.
Aber wie, wie, also in welchen Sphären muss man da in seinem Kopf schweben, dass man auf die Idee kommt, um zu sagen, okay, Windows im Arsch gewesen.
Linux waren die einzigen Sachen, die funktioniert haben.
Wir ersetzen jetzt Linux durch Windows.
Das muss man nicht verstehen.
Ja.
Aber so ist das halt im, äh, Business-Enterprise-Umfeld.
Da sind so, so, ähm, logische Entscheidungen aus technischer Sicht nicht mehr angesagt.
Da gibt es nur, äh, Stonks-Entscheidungen.
Und wenn irgendjemand entschieden hat, das wird so gemacht, dann wird das auch so gemacht.
Habe jetzt viel angegriffen und am Ende war es eingefangen.
Ich würde sagen, das war eher random, was eingefangen, weil wahrscheinlich irgendjemand nicht aufgepasst hat.
Keine Ahnung.
So genau kann ich das auch nicht erzählen.
Aber, zumindest, aber das, das, das, was ich eben erzählt habe, ne, das ist halt das, was jetzt rausgekommen ist.
Dass man, äh, Linux-Systeme durch Windows ersetzen will, obwohl nur Windows betroffen war.
Also wer das, wer das versteht.
Tja.
Naja.
Gibt Sachen, die muss man, die muss man nicht.
Die muss man nicht nachvollziehen können.
When your favorite streamer sees your post.
Oh, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Die letzte Animation war auch gut.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz Sound ausmachen.
Excellent.
When your favorite streamer sees your post.
Feels good, man.
Yo, champ.
Das ist die erste Animation, hast du die in der Ver...
Ach, Moment, ist das...
Ach, das, Moment, das ist das falsche.
Na klar, die haben wir, das haben wir doch schon gesehen.
Ne, passt doch.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das ist ein Follow-Up zu dem, zu dem anderen.
Ne, ach ne, das ist ja langweilig.
Das kennen wir ja schon.
Was, es gibt ein Follow-Up? Echt?
Was davon?
Alter, der Typ ist ja am...
Moment, das ist auf X, das will ich gar nicht haben.
Äh.
Das kenne ich, das meine ich doch.
Das haben wir, das haben wir das letzte Mal geguckt hier.
Und ich dachte...
Ich dachte, da drauf gibt es jetzt ein Follow-Up.
Weil er hat das Video...
Video gesehen und auch drauf, äh, reactet.
Guck her, da ist er doch am Start.
Das Making-of, ne, das...
Ah, das ist ja, das ist ja langweilig.
Ich dachte, es gibt irgendwas Neues.
Weil das war echt gut gemacht.
So.
Ähm.
Home-Pro-Beast.
Das haben wir, das haben wir uns doch schon angeguckt.
Kennen wir doch alle schon.
So.
Problem, da gucken wir uns...
Was gucken wir uns als erstes an?
Wir können uns als erstes eine Runde Battlefield angucken.
Wir gucken uns als erstes eine Runde Battlefield an.
So, zum Einstieg.
Das kann ich mich ein bisschen über die komischen Brain-Half-Car-Leute wieder aufregen.
Top.
Was, Battlefield 4 Moments?
Was, was interessieren mich irgendwelche Schneips?
Das haben wir doch schon gesehen.
Haben wir doch, das haben wir doch schon gesehen.
Best Moments in Battle...
Ah, Exit.
Exit.
Ja, es hat, es hat so ziemlich jeder schon mal reactet auf diese, auf dieses, ähm...
Time without your favorite streamer Video.
Wenn, wenn ich auf was reactet hab, das heißt ja schon was.
Also, wenn ich auf was reactet, dann könnt ihr von ausgehen, dass so ziemlich jeder andere, der, der reactet, schon reactet hat.
Ich bin damit sowas nicht so schnell.
So, komm, wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Exit.
Ih, Console Graphics.
Was ist das?
Console Graphics?
Bei, bei Battlefield 4 erkennt man es ganz gut hier unten am Steuerkreuz, aber...
Also von auf, von der Auflösung her, würde ich sagen, das ist, äh, Console Graphics.
Oder was meint ihr, Chad?
Ist das Console Graphics?
Welcome to the start of a special series.
In this one we're gonna be taking a look...
Oh!
...at the best clips that I've had sent in from Battlefield 3 over the past few years.
I've been doing this Topplay-Show for quite some time.
Ja, ja, guckt euch mal den Boden an, das müsste, das müsste, äh...
Bei, keine Ahnung.
Unten rechts, wenn sie nachladen.
Es könnte auch einfach PC sein mit schlechter Auflösung.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie schlecht Battlefield 3...
Wie schlecht Battlefield 3 auf der Konsole ausgesehen hat.
Niederhaltungstest, Alter!
Okay, das ist, das ist, das ist jetzt Xbox Gameplay.
So schlecht sah das gar nicht aus, ne?
So schlecht sah das gar nicht aus auf der Xbox.
Das Game sieht gar nicht so beschissen aus.
Also ich hab das jetzt schlechter in Erinnerung.
Eher für Nachladen.
Okay, dann, ähm...
Wacht, Moment.
Dann...
...hatte einfach nur eine schlechte Auflösung.
...quiet, but definitely worth it, as I was able to pick my favorite ones from over the years
and put them together into this video.
We'll be starting off with Battlefield 3 later on in the...
Ja, ich hab's auch gut aufgenommen und gerendert, aber dadurch wird ja die Grafik an sich nicht besser.
Also, ich, ich kann ja nur das, also maximal das anzeigen, was da ist.
Und das sah ganz gut aus, muss man sagen.
Ja, aber du hast insofern recht.
Viele Battlefield-Videos aus der Zeit damals war halt, ähm...
...aufgenommen mit, mit, äh, Kartoffel.
Wow!
Ach, cool, hier kommt's doch PC.
Ist einfach PC mit Kartoffel.
Mit Kack-Auflösung.
Wut, was hab ich da jetzt gesehen gerade?
Ich hab schon wieder voll vergessen, dass es ja sogar eine Armbrust in Battlefield 3 gab.
Die Granate haut rein, die geht voll ins Born.
Bam!
Ja.
In your face.
Das war irgendwie klar.
Die Granate ist schon, die ist exakt ins Born geflogen.
Also, nee, der Spawn ist da.
Die ist exakt dahin geflogen, wo die immer rumstehen.
Wenn sie in den Tunnel auf der anderen Seite gehen.
Ja, stimmt.
Damals haben halt viele mit, mit, mit dem Toaster aufgenommen.
Tag.
Geht es...
Ich muss euch jetzt mal was fragen.
Es gibt ja auch ein paar Leute, die, ähm...
...Battlefield gespielt haben früher.
So, ich hab ja, ich hab jetzt so die letzten Battlefields nicht mehr so großartig gespielt.
Weil es mir nicht gefallen hat.
Aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen.
Oder auch aus, aus, äh, generell, so aus allen möglichen Games.
So die Games, die man, die man, äh, besonders durchgesuchtet hat.
Es gibt so ein paar Audioschnipsel.
Die hat man, die fallen einem so random ein.
Wenn man einfach rumläuft oder irgendwie, irgendwie mal auf dem Klo sitzt oder so und an nichts denkt.
Dann fallen einem auf einmal irgendwelche Audiosamples oder irgendwie Audioschnipsels aus Spielen ein.
Ich hab, ich hab auch letztens einfach an nichts, so an nichts gedacht.
Und auf einmal hatte ich...
...so im Kopf, wie dieser Battlefield-Bad Company 2-Typ sagt...
...It's a Sniper!
Keine Ahnung warum.
Es gibt so ein paar Audios, äh, so ein paar Audiosachen.
Die haben sich voll eingebrannt.
Okay, Champ.
Cool, cool Story, Max, ja.
Es, die kriegst du einfach nicht mehr aus dem Kopf raus.
Oder zum...
Ja gut, den, den gibt's natürlich auch noch.
Ja, die, die Lademusik von Bad Company 2 auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ja, die ist natürlich auch nice.
Wobei, beste, beste Lademusik, die hier, finde ich.
Warte mal, warte mal.
LC2-Port, warte jetzt.
Beste.
Beste Lademusik.
Ey, übrigens, das geht ja noch ganze Ecke weiter.
Das läuft bloß nie im Game.
Okay, das ziemlich, aber...
...Bad Company 2 hat total viele Soundtrack-Stücke.
Die gingen viel länger als das eigentliche...
...als das eigentliche...
...was man im Game gesehen hat.
Da musstest du teilweise fünf Minuten rumstehen,
bis du alles gehört hast.
Bambi.
Nee, aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
die kriegst du nicht aus dem Kopf.
Oder auch...
Ich könnte wahrscheinlich heute noch...
Wobei, was heißt, was heißt könnte?
Habe ich, glaube ich, sogar,
wo wir Plague Mesa mal durchgespielt haben.
Oder fast durchgespielt haben.
Ich konnte ja noch mehr oder weniger...
...die, die, die fast die ganze Intro-Sequenz
mit der, in Half-Life mit der Bahn...
...mitsprechen, ja?
Also so oft habe ich das Kram gespielt.
Und mir ist letztens aufgefallen...
Wisst ihr, woran man wirklich merkt,
dass man alt wird?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da die Werbung heute noch da ist.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ach nee, Moment, ich sehe ja keine Werbung.
Oh doch, ich sehe...
Wo sehe ich Werbung?
Hier war...
Hier war eine Werbung letztens.
Und zwar...
Was, Retro oder so?
Hier war letztens eine Werbung.
Und dort...
Genau, das hier.
Da habe ich die Werbung gesehen.
So, und habe mir gedacht, okay.
Also, wenn das...
Wenn die Spiele,
mit denen man aufgewachsen ist...
Also jetzt mal so ein bisschen Mario 4...
Super Mario World, aber gerade Half-Life.
Also wenn eines der Spiele schlechthin,
mit denen man aufgewachsen ist,
heute in einem Retro-Magazin ist,
dann weißt du, du bist alt.
Ja, 1998.
War das.
Exzellent.
Das ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen.
Also, wenn das Retro ist, dann...
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
auch so geil ich die Spiele damals fand
und so schöne Erinnerungen ich an die ganzen Spiele von damals habe,
ich weiß nicht,
ich würde mir nie so ein Retro-Spiele-Magazin kaufen,
weil ich meine, wozu?
Klar, man kann da so ein bisschen in Erinnerung schwelgen,
ja, aber da kann ich mir auch irgendwie einen Speedrun vornehmen,
von Half-Life 1 angucken oder sowas.
Oder, ich weiß nicht, also, ich meine, die Spiele kenne ich ja alle.
Der einzige Punkt, wo ich in irgendwelche Spiele-Magazine reingucke,
ist eigentlich eh nur,
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal gucken will,
was sie zu irgendwas Neuem sagen oder so.
Ja, okay, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Stimmt, für die, die es damals noch nicht gab,
na, das ist tatsächlich ein Argument,
da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, ne, ich meine damit jetzt nicht nur gedruckte Sachen,
sondern beispielsweise auch bei der Gamestar auf der Website oder so.
Das Einzige, wenn ich da reingucke, ist,
wenn ich wissen will, was sie zu irgendeinem neuen Game sagen.
Früher habe ich ja, ich hatte ja mal eine Zeit lang sogar Gamestar abonniert,
ja, ich weiß auch, Paintschamp, ja,
aber ich habe damals übelst viel drauf gegeben,
was die Gamestar gesagt hat, so nach dem Motto,
wenn die Gamestar gesagt hat, das Spiel ist geil,
habe ich es mir gekauft, wenn die Gamestar gesagt hat,
das Spiel ist sackt, habe ich es mir nicht gekauft.
Wobei die Gamestar eigentlich,
die Gamestar eigentlich nie gesagt hat, dass das Spiel sackt.
Die haben zwar den Test so geschrieben, dass das Spiel sackt,
aber am Ende hatte das Spiel dann 72% oder so.
Also die Bewertung, die Bewertung war schon immer irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig.
So, die hatten ja, die hatten ja damals noch so ihre Zahlenwertung,
dieses von 0 bis 100 und da hast du Spiele gehabt,
da hast du den Test gelesen, hast dir gedacht,
oh, das Spiel muss aber sacken und am Ende hat es dann 74%.
Was eigentlich rein von der Bewertung gar nicht so schlecht war,
allerdings war es halt so, dass man sich damals eh nur Spiele gekauft hat,
die quasi 85 plus in der Gamestar gekriegt hatten, so nach dem Motto.
Wobei die, wobei die auch ganz schön daneben gelegen haben ab und zu.
Es gab ein paar Games, müsste ich jetzt mal in mich gehen,
die ich ganz gut fand, die in der Gamestar nicht gut weggekommen sind,
umgedreht auch, fällt jetzt aber gerade keins ein.
Gut, mein Half-Life ist auf jeden Fall überall gut weggekommen.
Das ist ja eines der bestbewertetsten Spiele aller Zeiten.
Egal, gucken wir weiter.
Früher war Gamestar auch noch okay.
Ach, ich finde, eigentlich geht die Gamestar immer noch.
Mann, die gehen halt mit der Zeit, was sollen die so machen?
Klar, die müssen halt auch ein bisschen Clickbait,
sowohl Video als auch Artikel und sonst was machen.
Ich bin auch kein Fan, dass du die Sachen nur mit Gamestar Plus angucken kannst.
Aber die müssen halt auch ein bisschen mit der Zeit gehen.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Ich finde, die Gamestar von den ganzen Spielemagazinen,
es gibt, finde ich, die Gamestar immer noch am besten.
Und es gibt ja gar nicht mehr so viele Spielemagazine.
Früher hattest du viel mehr Spielemagazinen,
auch viel mehr so PC.
PC, Zeitung, Magazin.
What the...
Moment, was?
Was war das?
Warte mal.
What?
Was ist das?
Wusstet ihr, dass das geht?
Ich kenne das nicht.
Und das Spiel ist, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre alt oder so.
Oder 8 Jahre.
Ich wusste nicht, dass das geht.
Das ist ja geil.
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Nee, echt nicht.
Poggers.
Das ist TDM?
TDM, hä?
Nee, das ist Tommy Lake.
Nee, das ist doch das TDM.
Oh, da stehen sie da und lassen sich von der Seite abschneibern.
Äh.
Was?
Ach, ach, ach, die, die Runde war vorbei.
Was ist das?
Ist das Metro?
Und er ist suppressed as fuck und man sieht nix?
Ich glaube, das ist Metro, oder?
So vom, so vom, vom Blauton her könnte das Metro sein.
Doch, das ist Metro, guckt euch die Map an.
Smoke und Suppression.
Guckt euch die Map an, das sind die Tunnel, das ist Metro.
Field 3 Episodes and mainly, I think, because of this clip.
Oh!
Geht's oder nicht?
Das kenne ich!
Den Clip kenne ich, den habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Den habe ich schon mal, das kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Zack.
Okay.
You want a shotgun in your face?
Operation Metro Streak mit dem 870 MCS dominiert das Gegenteil und bekommt sich 18 Töne in einem sehr kurzen Zeitraum.
Leider kann ich mich nicht erinnern, wer den nächsten Clip sendet, man kann den Gamertag natürlich sehen, aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern, wer es war. Es war entweder Big E oder Moriarty, es könnte jemand anderes gewesen sein, aber es war einer dieser beiden, glaube ich.
Bad Company 2 ging das ganz offiziell, also es ging immer, Battlefield 3 ging es teilweise nur manchmal.
Der BF4 Long Range God sniped in Battlefield 3. Okay, Champ.
Der wird jetzt die...
Der ist aber auch direkt auf ihn zugeflogen, aber es ist trotzdem nicht einfach, Jets zu treffen mit dem Panzer.
Oh, wenn der hittet.
Wow, der war huge.
Das war ja wirklich komplett ein Crossmap.
Oh, das war noch Zeiten.
Das war noch geil, Canister Shell über die halbe Map.
Und das Ding ging ja über die halbe Map.
Du konntest ja aus dem Spawn mit Canister Shell die Leute one-hitten.
Ja, Pless RNG gibt es ja nicht mehr, das Emote, das wurde ja entfernt.
Weil der Typ irgendwas angestellt hat, ich weiß gar nicht, ich will es gar nicht wissen.
One of the regular players on the top plays that sent in so many clips was Dexter.
This one is possibly my favorite.
It might not be the best in terms of kills, but it's Operation 925.
And I think one of the only clips that's featured on Operation 925.
Das ist Siebertower, ne?
Das war Poggers.
Da konnten sie sich richtig mit ihrem Destruction-Zeugs austoben.
Ja, Gegner, Kopf einschalten.
Okay, die Quali könnte Konsole sein, aber die Auflösung ist zu groß für Konsole.
War das nicht Siebertower? Sieht aber fast aus wie Siebertower.
They start of an episode, again an episode that did very well on YouTube.
You seem to enjoy the aggressive plays against camping enemies.
Alter, Leute!
Okay, die haben nicht nur keine Augen, die haben auch keinen Kopfhörer und keine Boxen an.
Die sind AFK.
Afklo.
... on Battlefield 3.
Let's jump back and watch this insane kit-switching streak on all of these enemies.
Aber trotzdem, extrem nicer Clip.
Also, das war wirklich ein Clip, den man hier in beste Momente reinnehmen kann.
Also, der war wirklich Poggers.
Die Gegner schießen nicht immer zurück, ja, das ist so.
Aber, ich mach mich ja da auch gerne drüber lustig, aber wie kriegst du mit zurückschießenden Gegnern solche Clips hin?
... Battlefield 3 Top-Players.
Er hat sich schon viele Clips an die originalen Top-Player auf Big Mooney's Channel gesendet.
Dieser, aber, wurde ein bisschen später an meinen Kanal gesendet.
Potentially, just as he gets back into creating some Battlefield-Videos.
It's probably the best Battlefield-Clip ever recorded.
... внимatel, ich seh' einen Tank-Verteidiger in eurem Umgebung.
Ah, das kennen wir schon.
Das kennen wir schon, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Oh, guck mal, der russische Crossbow.
Und jetzt, und jetzt noch in den Jet wieder rein, äh.
Ne, ich glaub das klappt nicht, nochmal in den Jet rein.
Aber trotzdem, das ist auch sowas, das kriegt...
Das ist sowas, das schaffst du einmal, während du das Game spielst, oder nie wieder.
... A quick, only in Battlefield-Moment from Axaville, playing on Caspian Border.
He takes down an enemy pilot, using only his sidearm.
Das fand ich... Es ist nicht realistisch, ne.
Es ist absolut unrealistisch, dass man solche Sachen machen kann.
Aber ich fand, das hat irgendwie dazugehört.
Und seit Battlefield 1 gehen ja so ganz abgedrehte Dinger nicht mehr.
Ich fand das halt übelst geil, mit dem Rausspringen aus...
Boah!
Pog!
Das war... Das war richtig cool.
Das war richtig cool.
Das war nice.
Das wollen wir uns gleich nochmal angucken.
Bam!
In your face!
Again, a few clips from Bombino Sniper, definitely worth watching.
Again, check out this for an incredibly lucky shot on Caspian.
Der ist einfach direkt reingeflogen.
Die Typen gingen mir immer so auf den Sack in Battlefield 3.
Es gab ja welche, nicht wie er, die das hier normal...
Halbwegs normal...
Naja, man kann nicht sagen, dass er das normal spielt.
Die das aber halt mobil spielen.
Und du hast Leute gehabt, die haben am Anfang nichts anderes mit dem Flugzeug oder mit dem Heli gemacht,
als auf diesen Kack-Turm zu fliegen und die gesamte Runde hier oben drauf zu campen.
Einfach... Die haben einfach die gesamte Runde...
Die haben einfach 30 Minuten auf diesem Ding gelegen und haben nichts gemacht.
Die haben auch noch nichts gekillt, nichts getroffen.
Die waren einfach nur 30 Minuten da.
Und am Anfang dafür aber alle Helis und alle Flugzeuge gecrashed.
Ich sehe schon Chat, ihr wart da auch dabei.
Der ist einfach so...
Also, er ist eigentlich ein Lamm.
Er ist ein Lamm, und er hat die echten Klips.
Dies...
Das ist natürlich...
Da hast du recht, Dr. Opossum.
Es gibt auch die Leute, die bleiben einfach im Spawn stehen, bis sie...
Ähm, mal einen Heli erwischen, um dann auf den Turm zu fliegen.
Das ist einfach verrückt.
Ey, gegen die Anti-Air Typen habe ich gar nichts, Captain Peng.
Wenn man dann mit Javelin und Sovlam auf dem Turm steht, ist vollkommen okay.
Aber die meisten Leute haben das ja nicht deswegen gemacht.
Die meisten Leute haben sich mit ihrem Sniper dahin geschlagen, dass er da auf dem Turm steht.
Aber die meisten Leute haben das ja nicht deswegen gemacht. Die meisten Leute haben sich mit ihrem Sniper da hingeholt.
hingelegt und haben durch Scope geguckt, 30 Minuten, hä? Der hat dann mit dem Crossbow
getroffen? Ne, mit was hat er den denn getroffen? Muss ja mit dem Crossbow gewesen sein, aber
die Quali war so verschwommen, ich habe ihn nicht mal schießen sehen.
Ach, Explosionsfall, ach, ja, ja, okay, jetzt ergibt es Sinn.
Die beste Headglitch-Posi, die beste Headglitch-Posi in ganz Battlefield 3, äh, guck mal, was
er zieht, ist hier hinter den Kisten, um die Ecke, da stehen so Kisten, die kannst du nicht
kaputt machen und da kannst du hier lang gucken und da lang gucken und geradeaus gucken, beste
Headglitch-Posi.
Ich meine, man muss schon, man muss schon die guten Positions ja wissen, ne?
Wer Headglitchen größer, nicht Headglitchen.
Hier, hier, da hinten.
Äh, ja, ja, hinter den Kisten da.
Äh, ja, ihr wisst was ich meine, hier.
Das ist ein Fehler, den ich nach wie vor immer noch in Battlefield mache, weil ich nicht
abwarten kann.
Ich spawn oftmals als Assault, stelle fest, es geht nicht weiter und springe in irgendeinen
Panzer rein und denke, auf geht's, aber eigentlich kannst du das sinnvollerweise nur als Engineer
machen, weil du kannst dich in, vor allem in random Games, nicht darauf verlassen, dass
sich irgendeiner repaired.
Wait, ist das Max FPS?
Weiß nicht.
Wer ist das?
Das ist der Friseur, genau.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Alter, der haut die aber weg.
Die zerreißt, übrigens das hier ist, ist, hier ist beste Headglitch-Posi.
Ähm.
Ey, die werden aber zerstört.
Der aimt auch die LMG richtig gut.
Ich hab da immer Probleme mit dem Panzer, weil die Sensitivität so unterschiedlich ist.
Was hast du denn für einen Twitch-Name?
Ja, einen anderen, weil ich diesen Account ursprünglich nie dafür gedacht habe, selbst
zu streamen.
Alter, die kriegen ja auch mega auf den Sack.
Ich hab den, ich hab den Twitch-Channel zwar auf YouTube verlinkt, aber ich hab mir gedacht,
ich mach da gar nicht so großartigen Wind drum, weil, ähm, du hast auf YouTube teilweise
schon ein bisschen merkwürdige Leute, die können ruhig auf YouTube bleiben, die müssen
nicht hier sein.
Ja, man kann die Sens umstellen beim Panzer, aber ich bilde mir ein, die Sens sind unterschiedlich
zwischen, ne, ne, zwischen LMG und, und, und, und, äh, ist gleich, oder?
Zwischen Panzer, LMG und Panzer-Main-Waffe ist gleich, die Sens.
Ich weiß das schon gar nicht mehr richtig.
YouTube-Nobbies.
Ja, auf YouTube, auf YouTube hast du teilweise ganz merkwürdige Leute, die will ich gar nicht,
dass die, dass die herkommen.
Und die guten Leute, die finden den Weg auch so her, so wie du jetzt.
Ähm, aber wenn die...
Ich hab letztens mal wieder aus Spaß Kommentare durchgeguckt unter einem alten Video, das sind
teilweise echt schon, schon gestört, Leute.
Übrigens, haha, ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Hat mir letztens einer auf, auf, auf, auf Twitter geschickt, wartet mal.
Ähm, ja, ja.
Ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, wartet mal.
Äh, weiß nicht, ob man das versteht.
Chat, ich hab einmal in meinem Leben einen Hate-Kommentar geschrieben.
Und wisst ihr bei wem, die Oldschooler werden ihn kennen, der aller echte Max-FPS-Black-Ops-1-Video,
richtig, richtig früh nach dem Release, hat der einfach auf dieser Schneemap den Siebener-Heli,
den man irgendwo auf die Map setzen musste, damit er dann da hinfliegt und da den Bereich patrouilliert,
hat der einfach Out-of-Map gesetzt.
Da hab ich ihm einen Hate-Kommentar geschrieben.
Ob er eigentlich zu doof ist.
Gerade auch nicht.
Auszuatmen und, äh, ja, zu doof ist, den Helikopter richtig einzusetzen.
Das war mein erstes und letztes Hate-Kommentar meines Lebens, jemals im Internet.
Was jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt's.
Was er gemacht hat, der hat mich unter den Kommentaren weggedisst und mich blockiert.
Was kann gut sein?
Kann, kann echt sein.
Ich mein...
Damals haben so viele Leute blöde Comments geschrieben.
Ey, meine Tastatur ist kaputt.
Ey, meine Tastatur ist gerade kaputt gegangen.
What the fuck?
Die ist neu.
Warum ist...
Nee, ey, warum ist, warum ist Hardware 2020 so scheiße?
Ohne Mist, ey.
Was ist das dann?
Hier, passt mal auf.
Ich hab eine Logitech G...
Ich hab 513 oder so.
Dieses Teil.
Wisst ihr, was gerade...
Hier.
Das da.
Es ist gerade die, die Control-Taste abgebrochen.
Es ist einfach die Control-Taste abgebrochen.
Wie, wie selber schuld.
Was kann ich denn dafür, wenn die Control-Taste abbricht?
Die Control-Taste ist ab.
Einfach weg.
Ich puste mal kurz ein bisschen den Dreck raus.
Den Staub, der so unter dem Kopf...
Ich mach euch da jetzt mal ein Foto von.
Alter, wie schlecht.
Wie schlecht.
Moment.
Wie mach ich da jetzt ein Bild am besten?
Von hier.
Wie schlecht.
So.
Alter, ich will da ein Bild von machen.
So, Moment.
Wie...
Alter.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich hab die Tastatur...
Wie lang...
Ich hab die doch hier...
Wir haben die doch sogar mehr oder weniger fast zusammen im Stream angeschlossen.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz das Bild hochladen.
Wir haben die doch fast im Stream zusammen angeschlossen.
Wie lang ist denn das her?
Das ist doch noch keine...
Das ist doch noch kein halbes Jahr alt, das Ding.
Ich lad mal kurz das Foto hoch.
Das ist ein halbes...
Wenn es hochkommt, ein halbes Jahr.
Und das kann doch nicht sein, dass...
Ich mein, ich werd mir jetzt kein Land...
Ich kleb das mit Heißkleber drauf oder so, ne?
Also ich kleb das wieder dran und gut ist.
Aber das kann doch nicht sein.
Okay, choose my image.
Ähm, Fotolibrary.
All photos.
Bild.
Done.
Steht der jetzt hoch?
Okay, also.
Ich hab's hochgeladen.
Ähm, äh, Upload ist hier.
Moment.
Ich hab jetzt keine Steuerungstaste.
Alter, ist das kacke.
Post image.
Ähm.
Hier, guck mal.
Ja, man erkennt es zwar noch.
Ich muss sie...
Ich muss sie kleiner machen.
Hallo?
Was ist das für ein Kack?
Hier, guck mal.
Ähm.
Ja, man erkennt es nicht richtig.
Äh, normalerweise hast du hier noch so Dinger, die dann in diesen Kopf...
Und hier dran...
Ihr seht das Plastik hier noch drin stecken.
Also die Taste machst du hier rein.
So.
Die sind noch da, die Stifte.
Aber die anderen Stifte sind abgebrochen und stecken hier drin.
Einfach, einfach ab.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Wie kann nach einem halben Jahr eine Taste abbrechen?
Was ist das denn?
Warum ist das alles so absolute billige...
Schrottqualität mittlerweile?
Doch, das ist doch lächerlich.
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Und davor schon die Maus, die den Geist aufgegeben hat.
Ich krieg die...
Ich krieg die Taste auch gar nicht mehr richtig drauf.
Das ist voll...
Voll im Arsch, ey.
Boah, das nervt mich jetzt.
Kaputte Tastatur ist das Schlimmste, was du haben kannst, ja.
So, ich hab's jetzt wieder drauf gemacht, aber...
Das wackelt wie Sau.
Naja, gut.
Ah.
Das ist schlimm.
Davor die Corsar-Tastatur, die auch rumgespackt hat.
Ne, davor hatte ich, davor hatte ich ne...
Äh...
K95.
Das Ding hatte ich davor.
So.
Ey, ich mein, das Zeug ist übelst teuer.
Das kostet 100...
Das sind Tastaturen für 100 Euro plus.
So.
Und was hatte die?
Die hat nach einem halben Jahr doppelte und dreifache Tastenanschläge...
Äh...
Tastenanschläge...
gemacht.
Warum ist das alles so nen Müll?
Zum Glück hab ich mir auf der Arbeit die hier gekauft.
Und die geht einfach.
Das Problem ist, an denen du hast keine gescheite Makro-Software.
Und...
Ähm...
Ja, deswegen hab ich mir die Logitech-Tastatur eigentlich gekauft.
Das kann's doch nicht beim besten Willen sein, ey.
Kann man Tasten nachbestellen?
Kann man bei Logitech...
Ähm...
Tasten kaufen?
Stimmt, stimmt.
Ah, Moment.
Ich guck mal Amazon.
Das...
Eig...
Eigentlich habt ihr recht.
Ich guck bei Amazon, wann ich das Ding bestellt hab.
Und dann...
Äh...
Tausche ich's um.
Logitech.
Geh.
Also.
Die ist...
Ich hab sie...
Ich hab sie bestellt am 28.
Dezember 2019.
Also sprich, die ist nach...
Äh...
Über...
Bisschen...
Bisschen über einem halben Jahr.
So ein Dreivierteljahr ist die im Arsch.
Aber ich kann die umtauschen, denke ich mal.
Angaben zur Bestellung.
Produkt Support.
Produkt Support erhalten.
Jetzt chatten mit Amazon.
Warum muss ich chatten mit Amazon?
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Das ist schon über...
Das ist schon ein Dreivierteljahr alt.
Da ist das bei Amazon nicht so.
Das geht, glaube ich, nur innerhalb der ersten...
Also innerhalb vom ersten Monat ist es bei Amazon total einfach.
Da kannst du direkt...
Direkt anklicken und alles ist gut.
Und, äh...
Ich glaube, das nächste halbe Jahr geht auch noch einfach.
Ansonsten musst du dann bei Amazon ein bisschen größer...
Aber trotzdem.
Es kann doch nicht sein.
Es kann...
Es kann echt nicht angehen, dass ich zwei Tastaturen hatte.
Und...
Und zwei...
Zwei high-end, übelst teure Tastaturen, die einfach den Geist aufgeben nach einem halben Jahr.
Äh, das ist eine G513.
Aber das ist doch Witz.
Das ist echt...
Ist echt...
So.
Okay.
Gut.
Naja.
Also ich habe jetzt die Taste behelfslich...
Wisst ihr, was ich mache?
Ich meine, die RGB-Beleuchtung juckt mich ja eh nicht.
Ich mache einfach Heißkleber drauf und papps fest.
Hast du immer so viele Tabs auf?
Ähm...
Ja.
Also...
Gut.
Jetzt habe ich die Videos auf, die wir uns heute angucken können.
Aber normalerweise habe ich auch teilweise...
Keine Ahnung.
50, 60, 100, 150...
Was auch immer.
Massig Tabs auf, ja.
Ich mache es auf der Arbeit immer so, einmal am Tag.
Äh...
Oder vielleicht kennt das ja der eine oder andere von sich.
Ähm...
Wenn das Notebook, das alte Notebook, hatte nur 8 GB RAM...
Und...
Äh...
Ich habe dann einmal am Tag alle Tabs zugemacht.
Das war dann meistens so, keine Ahnung, 14 Uhr habe ich festgestellt, dass mein Rechner halt nichts mehr großartig machen konnte.
Da musste ich einmal alle Tabs zumachen.
Ach so, und natürlich copy-paste ich mit, äh...
Ich copy-paste übrigens nicht mit Ctrl-C, sondern ich mache Ctrl-X.
Ctrl-X.
Weil Ctrl-X cuttet.
Gut.
So, genug über die Tastatur aufgeregt.
Aber ich bin...
Das ist echt crap.
Dann war das Mausrad an der Logitech-Tas...
Ähm...
Maus vorher kaputt.
Das ist alles übelster crap mittlerweile.
Ist echt Wahnsinn.
So.
Okay.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ähm...
Battlefield, Battlefield.
Ja.
Ähm...
Zumindest fand ich das geil, wo er erzählt hat, dass ich ihn gebannt habe.
Ich kann mich da wirklich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Aber kann gut sein.
Ich habe...
Äh...
Ich habe da teilweise mal so meine Tage auf YouTube, ja?
Also sprich...
Da gehen mir die Leute extrem auf den Sack.
Und egal, wenn einer was schreibt, wird er gebannt.
Ähm...
Ne, mittlerweile ist er glaube ich unbanned.
Also ich wüsste nicht, ob der noch...
Ne, glaube nicht, dass der gebannt ist noch.
Ähm...
So.
Was bei Rocket ist...
Also, äh...
Schreibt gerade jemand im Chat.
Rocket ist bei mir der Kleber ausgelaufen aus der Maus.
Also wie geht denn sowas?
Tja.
Aber hartig.
Ähm...
Kennst du die Fake-Ducky-Tastatur?
Ne.
Nein, nein, ich weiß meine Tastatur nicht durch den Raum.
Die Tastatur hier, die ist sogar im Vergleich zu früher ziemlich pfleglich behandelt worden, ja?
Da gibt es eigentlich nix.
Die Tastatur, der geht's gut.
Oder besser gesagt, der ist nicht so gut.
Der ist so gut.
Sollte es eigentlich gut gehen.
Ich meine, okay, die Tastatur geht halt...
Ich mach später ein bisschen Heißkleber drauf und papps fest.
Aber für so einen Preis, ja.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Early in Battlefield.
Moment, so in Battlefield.
Aber ich meine...
Warte mal, hab ich das noch auf?
Was mir nämlich gerade auffällt ist...
Ne, das war was anderes.
Ähm...
Moment, wo war ich gerade drauf?
Hier, die da, ne?
Was man hier auch ganz gut sieht ist...
Weil ihr seht ja hier das Plastik drin stecken.
Also das Plastik von hier...
Steckt da drin, das ist abgebrochen.
Und das ist wohl auch schon eine Weile so.
Weil, mir fällt nämlich gerade auf,
dass meine linke Control-Taste viel mehr wackelt,
als meine rechte Control-Taste.
Und das liegt daher, dass es wahrscheinlich schon lange abgebrochen ist.
Und jetzt ist es einfach hier neben rausgerutscht.
Und wenn man die Taste drückt und den Finger schnell wegmacht,
dann springt die auch von der Halterung runter.
Also ich mach später ein bisschen Heißkleber drauf und gut ist.
Ich tausch nicht um, weil...
Da muss ich jetzt erstmal irgendwie bei Amazon...
Näh, bisschen Heißkleber und gut ist.
Ja, gut, ich...
Wahrscheinlich werde ich es so machen.
Ähm, ich werde bei Amazon sagen, ich will umtauschen.
Und dann eventuell Heißkleber ist es auch noch.
Keine Ahnung, mal gucken.
Wobei, ne, Heißkleber ist doof.
Dann ist die Taste nicht mehr exakt eben wahrscheinlich.
Ja, du hast...
Ja, eigentlich...
Chat, Chat, Chat, Big Brain Chat.
Ja, eigentlich muss ich das umtauschen.
Die müssen ja in Scheiß wieder zurückkriegen, wenn es kacke funktioniert.
Äh, hat die Steckdose zu flashen geklappt?
Ach ja, die Steckdose.
Ähm, ich hab die Steckdose aufgeschraubt.
Vorgestern.
Und...
Also die hier, ne.
Wir haben ja im vorletzten Stream, haben wir ja versucht, ähm...
Ne, Moment.
Wir haben ja hier versucht, Steckdose zu flashen.
Für die, die nicht dabei waren.
Ich zeig das nochmal schnell.
Das Ding haben wir ja versucht zu flashen.
Hier oben, da, da liegt's.
Hier.
Und es hat nicht funktioniert, ne.
Die haben wir ja versucht zu flashen.
So.
Und die sieht original aus wie ne andere Steckdosenleiste, die ich habe, die man flashen konnte.
Und ich hab die aufgeschraubt.
Und hab reingeguckt.
Es ist ne andere CPU drin als das letzte Mal.
Es ist einfach ne...
Die Steckdosenleiste sieht exakt genauso aus wie die alte, aber es ist ne andere CPU drin.
Die kann man nicht flashen.
Skamaz.
So.
Und zum Glück hab ich die äußerst vorsichtig aufgeschraubt.
Und hab die jetzt zurück an Amazon gekauft.
Also sprich, wieder zugeschraubt, eingepackt, zurück an Amazon geschickt.
Das sind die Cogeek-Steckdosenleisten, genau.
Nur, dass die original so aussah wie die Cogeek-Steckdosenleiste, die sich flashen lassen hat.
Und aber ne andere CPU drin ist, die man nicht flashen kann.
Da war irgendein Mediatek-CPU drin, anstatt ein ESP2866.
Jaja, Serious Max, schmeiß das wieder weg.
Weil, die geht nicht.
Und die schmeißen...
...die in den Müll, wahrscheinlich.
Zumindest krieg ich mein Geld wieder.
Manchmal bringt Amazon solche Sachen auch als so, was ist es nicht, Warehouse-Deals, ne wie heißt das bei Amazon, diese Second-Hand-Dinger, wo es sie teilweise billiger gibt.
Ne, Basics nicht. Warehouse-Deals sind's, glaub ich.
Was ist mit dem los?
Stimmt, stimmt, ich vergaß, Battlefield 3-Physics.
Und jetzt noch ein Messer, genau.
Also die Taste springt, ich hab's grad ausprobiert, die Taste springt einfach runter.
Und das hier ist einer meiner Lieblings-Battlefield-3-Spieler.
Er spielt in dem Attack-Helikopter viel, vor allem als Roboter.
Und er drückt so Clips wie das.
Absolut verrückt.
Der zweite, ein richtig schöner Schuss, aber das Spiel kommt ihm dieses Mal.
Und leider gibt es auch Durst.
Hahaha.
Lol.
Voll reingeknallt!
Scream scheint ein beliebter Name zu sein. Es gibt doch auch einen CSGO und Valorant Spieler.
Und der halt echt gut ist, ne?
Aber den schreibt man anders.
Beste Waffe. M416. Hau raus.
Legehähne.
Also rein von Waffe und Objective und die Stelle, das könnte ein Clip von mir sein.
Also mal davon abgesehen, dass ich so Clips eher nicht reißen würde.
Aber da kann ich mich sehr gut mit identifizieren.
Oh, da wird der Heli repariert.
Das sind auch die Geilsten. So nach dem Motto, ah ja, M kommt fliegend los.
Er durfte erstmal kurz den Brenner rausholen.
Das ist ein geiler Clip. Das ist ein richtig geiler Clip.
Dass er auch noch den Launcher gekriegt hat, das ist ein richtig nicer Clip.
Richtig pock.
Hast du für Traffic Fail to Balance den? Ne, weil ich den nicht extern laufen habe.
Oh, Little Bird Damavan Peak hinten durch den Tunnel.
Das ist ein guter Clip.
Wisst ihr, was ich damals immer gerne gemacht hätte, was wir aber nicht hinbekommen haben?
Auch erstens, weil wir nicht genug Spiele hatten und weil wir auch nicht in der Lage waren, das ordentlich aufzunehmen.
Wir haben es, ich habe es mit dem Kabu mal, ein paar Mal haben wir es ja versucht, so dieses Duel, also aus zwei Perspektiven aufgenommen, die Runde.
Aber ich habe es mir damals immer ultra geil vorgestellt, wenn man mal wirklich mit einem Vierer Squad spielt.
Also so richtig eingespielt und gut im Vierer Squad spielt.
Wenn man zwischendurch die Perspektiven wechselt, dass man vier Leute hat, die richtig gut spielen, die richtig gut zusammenspielen.
Jeder nimmt auf.
Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Und du wechselst dann die Perspektiven dazwischen.
Zum Beispiel, du gehst dann halt kurz in die Medic Perspektive, siehst wie der eine Typ gerettet wird, switchst die Perspektive zu dem, wie er gerade gerettet wird und dann fünf Leute killt oder sowas.
Das habe ich mir immer richtig geil vorgestellt.
Aber damals hat es daran gemangelt.
An der Menge der guten Spieler, an den Spielern, die wir zusammen gespielt haben und nichts.
Und zum Schluss, dass damals halt Capture Equipment jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig, hatte nicht jeder, also es hatte nicht jeder gute Spieler Capture Zeug.
Da hast du ja auf der Konsole noch gespielt.
Heute auf dem PC weniger das Problem.
Felix, ja, das ist, ich stelle mir auch vor, dass man das richtig, richtig gut angucken kann.
Alter, der zerlegt die auch richtig.
Alter.
Die waren halt auch teilweise sehr robust, die Helis hier, ne?
Wait a minute, das geht?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man mit dem Little Bird den Panzer-Damage machen kann.
Wie sieht es bei dir mit einem neuen Game aus?
Ja, da muss ja erstmal ein ordentliches Game rauskommen.
Das einzige, was ich aktuell ab und zu mal spiele, ist Path of Exile.
Cold War, oh, Cold War sieht so billig aus, ne?
Ich sage es euch jetzt mal, wie so mein Empfinden ist, aber Cold War sieht so Modern Warfare Reskin billig aus.
Das werde ich mir erst gar nicht holen.
Es schießt keiner zurück, ja, das stimmt.
Also ganz ehrlich, gerade hier, wenn der so durch den Tunnel fliegt, könnte man den auch super mit einem Assault Rifle hier vorne rausschießen.
Herz 93 habe ich gelesen, ich habe aber die League nicht gespielt und ich werde die League wahrscheinlich auch nicht spielen.
Leider ist, leider ist Spellslinger nicht mehr, ja, aber das macht nichts.
PoE gibt so viele, so viele Bills.
Another clip from Dexter.
I thought I'd include a few concerns.
He did send in the best part of 50 clips.
Oh, eine Runde Bazaar.
Guck mal, so sieht Bazaar mit High Settings aus.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das Spiel auch auf High Settings spielen kann.
Ich habe das immer auf Low Settings.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Wand so hoch aufgelöst ist.
Teen Man on the classic Grand Bazaar using the M416.
Und dass hier so viel Zeug rumliegt und alles.
Gut, das ist von der Wand hier.
Aber ich kenne das Spiel nur in Low Settings.
Das sieht tatsächlich viel besser aus in High Settings.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Oh, hast du irgendwo das Sound?
Ja, ist eigentlich total hängen geblieben.
Ich habe einen super Rechner, auch nach der Zeit noch.
Und ich spiele ein 8 Jahre altes Spiel auf Low.
Aber dafür hast du halt konstant 300 FPS so in dem Dreh.
Das hängt halt am Limit so.
Den Sound hätte ich ein bisschen fixen müssen.
Das hat mich damals auch genervt.
Das weiß ich ja immer, wenn ich Clips zugeschickt bekommen habe.
Die Hälfte der Clips war Sound und Video asynchron.
Da musste ich jedes Mal, wenn ich quasi Gameplays verwendet habe, die nicht von mir waren,
muss ich immer Sound und Bild alle zwei Minuten synchronisieren.
Da dachte ich mir mal, Leute, könnt ihr das richtig aufnehmen?
Was für einen Monitor verwendest du? Das kann ich dir zeigen.
Ich glaube, da haben wir keinen Reflink.
Wir könnten tatsächlich mal einen Reflink machen.
Ich habe einen BenQ X...
Ja, gute Frage, wie heißt denn der nochmal?
BenQ...
Was habe ich für einen Monitor?
Moment, Twitter, Twitter.
Ich poste doch jeden Mist auf Twitter.
Ja, excellent.
Also, den habe ich.
Gut.
Mein Monitor ist, glaube ich, nicht aktuell hier in dem verlinken.
Nein, nein, der Monitor ist der alte Monitor.
Das ist nicht aktuell bei Ausrufezeichen-Hardware.
Das müssen wir tatsächlich mal updaten.
Den da habe ich jetzt.
Einen XL2546S.
Den gibt es erst seit 1-2 Monaten.
Also, den gibt es noch nicht so lange.
Es gibt hier den Vorgänger.
Der ist ohne S.
Den würde ich mir jetzt aber nicht mal kaufen.
Ich würde mir den neuen kaufen.
Das ist der alte.
Ich würde immer nur den neuen holen, den da.
Der hat keinen Lüfter.
Irgendwie kann es sein, dass der neue nicht lieferbar ist oder so.
Ist der neue nicht lieferbar?
Doch.
Nee.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ah, Alternate, okay.
Äh, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja.
Nein.
Warum ist der nicht lieferbar?
Hä?
Okay, ich verstehe es nicht.
Aber zumindest den habe ich.
Sag mal, kann es sein, dass es den irgendwie instant nicht mehr gibt oder was?
New.
Okay, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Ehrlich gesagt, warum es das irgendwie nirgendwo mehr zu kaufen gibt.
Aber okay.
Hardware-Schotter.
Muss mal bei Geizhals gucken.
Warum gibt es das denn gerade nicht zu kaufen?
Das Monitor gibt es doch eigentlich immer.
Kein...
What?
Warum?
Ist das...
Könnte das echt wegen Corona sein, dass sie den nicht hergestellt bekommen gerade?
Sehr komisch.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Weil das ist erst seit ein, zwei Monaten draußen, das Ding.
Und warum gibt es das nicht mehr?
Sehr merkwürdig.
Na gut, zumindest ist das der Monitor.
Das ist übrigens eine sehr berechtigte Frage, warum das immer so dreckig ist.
Hast du dir das Spiel Squad angeschaut?
Ja.
Vor drei Jahren oder so, als es Early Access war und auch keine Schatten hatte.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, nee, kein Bock.
Vielleicht lohnt sich das wieder anzuschauen, ja.
Oh, die P90 hatten sie ja auch in Battlefield 3.
Hat bloß kaum einer gespielt.
Siebertower.
Das ist Siebertower, oder?
Ich bringe das immer durcheinander.
Das ist doch jetzt Siebertower, oder?
Oh, die hat er aber schön umflankt, kann man das nicht nennen, umsprungen.
Das war der Spickschack so.
Ey, der Pointstrip gehört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Das ist das passende Gameplay für mich.
Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte.
So muss das sein.
Bam.
Genau mein Style.
Das hat mich in Modern Warfare immer umgebracht.
Weil ich zu viel aus der Hüfte geschossen habe.
Exzellent.
Alter, solche Sachen gehen mir immer.
Oh, wenn ich das sehe.
Okay, der geht jetzt ja, der killt ja noch was, der Typ, ne?
Aber diese Leute, die permanent im Spawn gestanden haben und nur gesniped haben.
Wie mich das genervt hat.
Vor allem, wenn du ein halbes Team voll hattest.
No one gets close to Big E.
A 5200 point chain from his own carrier onto enemies in the distance.
Absolutely absurd.
Vor allem als Attacker.
Genau, Trio.
Oh, der macht aber schon echt heftige Shots hier, ne?
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Das sind schon erstklassige Shots.
Wenn du solche in deinen Squads hattest, ja.
Das ist aber wirklich ein Poggers-Feed.
Oh, der Typ wieder, den hatten wir auch schon öfters.
Und immer an dieser Stelle, exakt da und sie haben Build Interpolation an.
Was nur absolute Low Brains machen.
Genau, der sitzt immer da oben und macht immer das gleiche, der Typ.
Ich konnte es nie selbst erreichen.
Was für ein verrückter Spieler.
Einer der lustigsten Clips, die in den...
Wie?
Das war's jetzt?
Ich meine, nicht schlecht, aber...
Okay.
... Top-Player und auch ein verdammt glücklicher.
Das war mein Hero Love, der mit einem Roadkill mit dem kleinen Pferd auf Damavan kam.
Die ganzen Schneiber-Dudes.
Exzellent.
Und noch ein Clip von Big E.
Eine 4.300-Punkte-Chain.
Auf der ganzen Rückseite der Map von Firestorm.
Er ist so weit zurück, wie du gehen kannst.
Und er...
Nichts.
Auch wenn es geil anzusehen ist.
Was hältst du von der Stalker-Spiel-Serie?
Richtig geil.
Aber wobei, Serie.
Ich meine, es gibt ja nur Teil 1.
Es gibt jetzt irgendwann...
Irgendwann mal, glaube ich, soll es Stalker 2 geben oder so.
... mehr Töne, als die meisten auf diesem Spiel machen.
Tristan of Numenals kommt mit einem Smoke-Rambo-Clip.
Wieder einmal jemand, der in sehr wenige Clips gesendet hat.
Alle sehr exakt.
Wenn das auf der Xbox gewesen wäre,
und das zu Zeiten, sagen wir mal, so 2011 rum,
der hätte danach 20 Voice-Messages bekommen
von irgendwelchen Kindern, die ihn beleidigt hätten.
Also, das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen.
...Rambo-Clips auf Metro.
Dieser ist einfach verrückt.
Er zerstört das Gegenteil in Rekordzeit.
Sagen wir mal, Gegner, dreht euch doch mal um!
Was ist denn los?
Was ist denn los mit euch?
Bewegt euch mal!
Ja, aber...
Es gibt doch...
Hä?
Moment, es gibt doch nur Stalker 1.
Und jetzt gibt es irgendwann Stalker 2.
Also, das einzige Stalker, was ich kenne, ist Stalker Call of Pripyat,
oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Das andere sind wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Mods oder so, ne?
Echt?
Okay.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich kenne bloß das, was damals, frag mich nicht, 2005 oder so,
oder 2004, oder wann das mal rausgekommen ist.
Aber Stalker ist richtig ein Commodore-Game.
Hast du die neue Steckdosenleiste eigentlich geflasht bekommen?
Nee.
Hat die falsche CPU drinne.
Geht nicht.
Hab ich zurückgeschickt in Amazon.
Wisst ihr was, Leute?
Das könnte...
Denkt euch mal...
Denkt euch mal den Crossbow weg.
Das könnte ne Battlefield 1 Map sein.
Sowohl von den Häusern her,
als auch von den Farben her.
Äh, nee, nee, nicht ne B... äh...
Battlefield 1?
Battlefield...
Battlefield 5?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Battlefield 5 mein ich, glaub ich.
Wie gesagt, ich hab so wenig gespielt.
Aber das ist, äh...
Sand Crossing.
Und ein Objektiv, das Kappen benötigt.
BB-Gas, äh...
Exzellent.
So.
Jetzt haben wir uns wie immer ne Runde Battlefield gegeben.
Das... das musste sein.
Wisst ihr, was ich gut finde?
Bei dem?
Ähm...
Dass das bei...
Dass man bei ihm noch sieht, dass man...
Mit Battle...
Dass man auch mit Battlefield Content noch ein paar Leute erreichen kann.
Ich mein...
Das macht ja wirklich nur Battlefield.
Es ist jetzt nicht mehr huge wie...
Views wie irgendwie 2012 oder so.
Aber ich mein, es geht noch.
Ja.
Allerdings, was man daran auch, äh...
Sieht ist...
Die müssen...
Das nächste Battlefield muss was taugen.
Wenn das nächste Battlefield nichts taugt...
Äh...
Dann ist, glaub ich, echt vorbei.
Ich weiß nicht, wie's mit Spieler...
Mit Player Base aussieht, ehrlich gesagt.
Keine Ahnung.
Angeblich ist die Player Base ja ganz super toll bei 1 und 5 gewesen.
Und alles ganz geil.
Ähm...
Aber...
Hype-mäßig und Viewermäßig ist Battlefield halt absolut tot.
Seit Battlefield 1.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist der Witz.
Ja.
Äh...
Dann guckt euch das mal an.
Ja.
Der Witz.
Weil...
Weil die...
Ja.
Was ist das?
121 Viewer.
Versteh ich nicht.
Ich hab mehr.
Ich hab mehr Viewer als Battlefield 5.
Weltweit.
What the fuck?
Äh...
Heute wird der Erfolg eines Spiels an Twitch-Zuschauern gemessen.
Ja.
Natürlich.
Es ist...
Es ist ja...
Es ist ja so.
Guckt ihr die großen Spiele an?
Äh...
Die, die gehypt sind.
Die, die angesagt sind.
Die, die viel gespielt werden.
Die sind auf Twitch auch beliebt.
Ich mein, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Du wirst bestimmt ein paar Ausnahmen finden.
Aber zum größten Teil kannst du ziemlich gut anhand der Twitch-Performance erkennen,
wie viel gerade gespielt wird.
Guck dir die Steam-Stats an und guck dir...
Sogar Warframe wird geguckt.
Warframe wird auch geguckt.
Ich mein, es ist jetzt zwar nicht ultra, aber es ist...
Und abends hast du teilweise auch ein paar größere Warframe-Streamer.
Ähm...
Es ist...
Es ist keine 121...
121 ist halt absolut nichts.
Das Einzige, wo ich sag, wo das...
Wo das nicht so ist, sind asiatische MMOs und solche Sachen, weil die halt nicht so sehr
auf Twitch streamen.
So Asia-MMOs, die irgendwie Millionen Spieler und sowas haben.
Das ist auf Twitch nicht so extrem angesagt, aber die streamen, glaub ich, auch auf anderen
Plattformen nicht so sehr auf Twitch.
Aber ansonsten, du kannst das ziemlich gut.
Wenn du...
Wenn du Steams...
Wenn du die Steam-Stats dir an...
Äh, nicht...
Stats, Stats, Alter.
Wobei, die heißen Charts mittlerweile, die Seite, oder?
Ja, so mittlerweile Steam-Charts.
So.
Hat viele Zuschauer.
Hat viel...
Naja, hat so...
Naja, okay.
Hat nicht so viele Zuschauer.
Hat viele Zuschauer.
Hat...
Frag mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann nicht sein.
Ähm...
Left 4 Dead 2 gab's jetzt erst einen neuen Mod.
Muss ich vorstellen, die haben...
Äh, Left 4 Dead 2 haben seit...
Die haben jetzt einen Mod bekommen.
Seit 7 Jahren, oder so, mal wieder.
Geht so.
Geht auch so.
Gucken auch recht viele.
Ah ja.
Source SDK Base 2013 Multiplayer.
Absolute Favorite Game.
Rust gucken auch.
Destiny 2 gucken auch.
Fall Guys gucken auch viele.
Ja, also...
Du kannst...
weniger hier fast 1 zu 1 gucken,
was auf Twitch auch beliebt ist.
Es mag Ausnahmen geben, aber zu 90%
kommt es hin. Das ist ein gutes
Bild, wobei Among Us,
äh, nee, nee, nee, nicht, ähm,
ist auch, ist auch
ein, ich glaube, für
beispielsweise für Fall Guys könnte man ein ähnliches
Bild machen.
Das sind Spiele,
die mit dem
Twitch-Hype, also
durch den Twitch-Hype gewachsen sind.
Du hast Spiele, die bringen
eine gewisse Playerbase mit, die zieht's
dann auf Twitch, wenn die Leute zugucken wollen. Also
sagen wir mal, würden wir jetzt mal sagen, es kommt
wirklich mal ein gutes neues Battlefield raus,
das würden viele spielen und würden
sich dann auch gute Spieler auf Twitch angucken
oder CSGO. Die Leute spielen
CSGO und wollen sich gute Spieler,
wollen sich gute Spieler
auf Twitch angucken.
Aber sowas wie Fall Guys und
Among Us, das sind
halt Spiele, die sind hauptsächlich
durch Twitch
Geschichten so beliebt
geworden. Allerdings, ein Problem
muss es bei Fall Guys extrem
geben und zwar ist es Gecheate.
Weil alles Client-Side berechnet wird,
was halt Fail ist für ein Multiplayer-Spiel.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab das
nicht gespielt, ne. Ich hab's auch,
es ist auch nicht so mein Time-Spiel.
Aber ist das nicht ähnlich,
wie die früher, wie die
auf YouTube früher immer Trouble in Terrorist
Town und sowas gespielt haben?
Ist das nicht das ähnliche Spielkonzept?
Also quasi
irgendeiner ist Verräter und die
anderen müssen überleben oder sowas?
Also soweit ich das aus Streams
gesehen hab. Das ist
natürlich ein super Spielkonzept für Twitch.
Ach ja, stimmt. Fall Guys,
wo wir gerade beim Thema
Linux Gaming waren.
Wir haben doch ein Video zum Thema Linux Gaming.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema
Linux Gaming waren.
Fall Guys hat wunderbar
unter Linux funktioniert. Wisst ihr
bis wann?
Wartet mal, bis wann hat Fall Guys gut unter Linux
funktioniert? Korrekt!
Bis Anti-Cheat eingeführt
wurde. Seitdem geht's nicht mehr.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema Gaming unter Linux
sind. Es ging, es ging,
es ging. Anti-Cheat.
Bam, Painschamp.
Okay, dann hören
wir uns mal an, was er zum Thema Linux Gaming zu
sagen hat.
Moment, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, da kommt
irgendwas drunter. Moment, müssen wir uns
den jetzt sechs Minuten lang angucken?
Hat er nicht ein paar Bilder?
Okay, egal.
I'm about to give.
So, if you take offense to this video, please
know. Meine Meinung dazu kennt ihr, ne?
Linux Gaming. Da muss ich jetzt
nicht nochmal breitreden.
I hope I'm wrong. I just wanted to tell you
what I think from a business standpoint
about this. Gut, lohnt sich nicht.
Microsoft acquiring Bethesda
or ZeniMax and all
of its subsidiaries. Sag mal, der hat
irgendwie einen Filter über seinem Mikrofon,
dass es keine
Höhen mehr hat, oder? Oder hat er
eine Stimme ohne jegliche Höhen?
ID Software. So, Doom, Quake,
Fallout, all those now fall under
Microsoft's umbrella.
This means a lot of things
and really bad for
the open source community and
probably Linux Gaming as a whole.
So, let's look at it.
Because right now
in the past year of 2020, we
haven't seen a lot of Vulkan games, but
the ones we did see, the biggest ones,
came from Bethesda. Das stimmt.
Ja gut, die
id Software ist ja dafür bekannt, dass die
OpenGL machen, schon
diese ganze Doom-Geschichten waren ja schon immer
OpenGL und
jetzt wahrscheinlich Vulkan, ja.
Seit Anfang an.
So, this does mean that we're probably gonna
have a little more vendor lock-in.
As you know, most things that Microsoft
owns, they put on the Windows
Dota Underlords.
Das ist auch so ein absolutes Fail-Game geworden.
... or the Microsoft Store.
And this does not work in Linux
at all. So I can see them
doing a lot more lock-in, which
is absolutely terrible.
And does this mean...
Okay, der erzählt nichts Neues, müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Langweilig.
Es ist, ja klar,
dass der Microsoft Store nicht unter Linux funktioniert, ist logisch.
Und dass es
nicht gerade mehr Linux-Games geben wird
durch den Kauf von Bethesda
von Microsoft, ist auch irgendwo klar.
I won 100
by picking... Ah, den haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Excellent.
... lock-picking lawyer and every once in a while
my big mouth gets me into trouble.
Everything started a few weeks ago
with an email from a locksmith
who happens to be local to me in the
D.C. area. He emailed me
about a quick-set smart-key padlock
just like this one, but his
came to him without a key
and he couldn't pick it open.
I may have been a little bit overzealous
in explaining the... Okay, wir haben
jetzt ein paar Videos von dem schon gesehen. Ich weiß jetzt,
wie das läuft. Die Videos laufen
immer relativ wenig.
Zumindest viele.
Er holt jetzt irgendwie eines seiner
super-big-brain-Tools raus,
schiebt
dieses Tool in das
Schloss rein, wackelt ein bisschen und das Schloss ist offen.
Glaubst du, es kommt noch was
für die Playstation von Bethesda? Ja, garantiert.
Okay, garantiert ist nix.
Es ist Microsoft letztendlich.
Aber mich würde es wundern, wenn sie sich das
entgehen lassen. Das ist halt die
Abwägung. Was bringt
mehr? Die Kohle von der
anderen Plattform oder die Leute,
auf die eigene Plattform?
Letztendlich als PC-Spieler ist es allerdings nicht
so wild, weil die meisten Microsoft-Sachen ja auch für
PC kommen. Aber ich gehe schon
stark von aus, dass ein neues Doom
sowohl für die Xbox als auch
für die Playstation erscheinen wird.
Das würde mich echt wundern, wenn alles jetzt
auf einmal Xbox-exklusiv wäre.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine,
geldmäßig
hat Microsoft ja da keine Probleme.
Die haben, gerade
in Europa, haben die Markt-Anschlüsse
Anteilsprobleme, was Konsolen angeht.
In den USA ist die Xbox ja relativ beliebt.
In Japan spielt die Xbox absolut
oder generell in asiatischen
Ländern, hauptsächlich in Japan, spielt
die Xbox halt so gut wie gar keine Rolle.
Und in Europa
war es so zur 360-Zeiten
ganz gut, aber die Playstation war
besser. Aber gerade Deutschland ist
halt so ein Playstation-Land. Das weißt du,
das hast du ja damals schon dran gesehen. Aber Max,
Playstation-Beste, scheiß
Fickbox.
Wixbox, sorry. Nicht Fickbox,
Wixbox war es ja damals.
Okay, also
das Video,
also manchmal spoilert die Videozeit
auch den Ausgang. Er hat jetzt
weniger als drei Minuten Zeit
und er muss es in drei Minuten schaffen.
Hm, ob er es wohl schafft?
Wir werden nie drauf kommen.
Ja, auf.
Go, go. Excellent.
Erstmal schön das Paket
durchschnibbeln. So macht man das.
ASMR-Unboxing.
Okay, das machst du nicht einfach kaputt mit dem Hammer.
And it looks like I got a Ford car lock as well.
You'll probably see that in a future video.
Okay, I also have a...
Oh, there we go.
A little timer.
Ich könnte wetten, das ist gestellt.
Also, der hat das vorher
schon mal ausgepackt, hat sich das
angeguckt und hat es dann wieder eingepackt.
And,
okay, let's start
the timer and
see if my big mouth is
something I can
back up with words.
Or with actions, I should say.
Click out of one, nothing on
two, three.
Okay, four, click out of him.
Still binding.
Okay, I think four is set.
Five binding.
Okay, I'm using
a bouncing technique. I feel like
five might be set.
One, two, okay, three.
Three is definitely binding.
Okay, three feels set.
Probably four, five.
Back to the beginning.
One is binding tightly.
In Skyrim wäre es schon durchgebrochen.
Click out of one.
Okay, one feels set.
Two binding tightly.
Two is probably set.
Three.
Binding tightly, excellent.
Okay, four feels set.
Nothing on five.
Okay, three.
Okay, two bind tight.
Zack.
Okay, I probably got a little...
Excellent.
Also im Prinzip exakt so,
wie ich das prediktet habe.
Er holt irgendwelche geilen Tools aus,
wackelt ein bisschen im Schloss rum
und es ist offen.
Easy clap.
Übrigens, mir ist jetzt wieder eingefallen,
warum mir der Name so bekannt von dir vorkam,
Solar von Astor.
Das ist dieser Dark Souls NPC-Typ.
Ich habe mir jetzt den Namen, kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ich habe erst gedacht, es wäre irgendwie ein antiker Grieche oder so vom Namen her.
Jetzt ist mir, das ist der Dark Souls, der Typ mit dem Helm, Alter.
Exzellent.
So, da hier, ja was weiß ich, wie man den Typ ausspricht.
Dark Souls NPCs reden ja auch, also Dark Souls NPCs,
es könnte eigentlich mal einer irgendein Dark Souls NPC Dialog ASMR Video oder sowas machen.
Die reden ja schon so, die ganze Zeit.
Ja, der mit dem Helm, genau.
Max, wann magst du was von deiner Streamliste?
Machst du was von deiner Streamliste?
Du meinst das hier?
Ja, laufend machen wir da was von.
Wir machen doch total oft was davon.
Es gibt halt ein paar Sachen, die stehen schon länger drauf.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre die Liste jetzt so cool,
es ist ja nicht so kurz, das machen wir, wahrscheinlich machen wir mal eins von den beiden als nächstes.
Weil Vue.js 3 ist jetzt raus, das wollte ich mir eh schon mal angucken.
Und es gibt jetzt ein .NET 5 Preview, wo man 1090 Sharp Features angucken kann.
TempleOS, oh, TempleOS ist halt so ein Ding.
Eigentlich ist es komplett sinnlos, weil du damit nichts gescheites machen kannst.
Und, und, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommt, der TempleOS-Typ hat sich ja umgebracht.
Und man weiß nicht, ob er sich umgebracht hat, er wurde vom Zug überfahren.
Aber der Zugführer meint, der Typ wäre halt in den Zug gelaufen.
Und wenn man sich die Videos anguckt von dem,
der Typ hat den übelsten Dachschaden gehabt, der TempleOS.
Also, muss ich mal kurz ein bisschen ausholen.
TempleOS ist ein Betriebssystem, was von einem Mann programmiert wurde, nämlich von dem Typ hier.
Und angeblich, angeblich, muss man sich mal überlegen,
angeblich hat er quasi den Aufwand, den er hat, den er hat, den er hat, den er hat, den er hat.
Und er hat den Auftrag, diesen Tempel als Betriebssystem zu bauen, von Gott persönlich empfangen.
Und Gott hat ihm auch erklärt, wie er das programmieren soll.
Also erstens benötigt man eine extra Programmiersprache dafür, nämlich Holy See.
Das hört sich jetzt an wie irgendwie so eine, genau, Holy See, also irgendwie so eine C-Abwandlung.
Und Gott hat gesagt, man darf keine Grafikkarte verwenden.
Man muss, ähm, warte mal, hier, hier, genau.
Genau, 46x480 Auflösung, 16-Color-Display, Audio,
und das hat ihm Gott höchstpersönlich in irgendeiner Vision mitgeteilt,
dass das so gemacht werden muss.
Und er hat irgendwie 16 Jahre oder so daran rumprogrammiert.
Also der Kerl hat wirklich den übelsten Dachschaden gehabt.
Also der war ja auch nachweislich schizophren und hat Medikamente genommen
und der war wirklich komplett durch, ja.
Und, ähm, da ist kein Wunder, dass Gott mit ihm spricht.
So wie Dr. House mal gesagt hat, spricht Gott mit dir, bist du religiös,
sprichst du mit Gott, bist du verrückt.
Und bei ihm war das wahrscheinlich eher das Zweite.
How to mod a video, oh, das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Das will ich nämlich demnächst auch mal im Stream machen.
Nein, Trollomat hab ich noch nicht.
Aber es gibt jetzt, es gibt, das hab ich ja vor einer Weile schon mal in der News gelesen,
es gibt jetzt einen Rosenkranz.
Es gibt jetzt einen, ähm, App und einen, genau, ein smarter Rosenkranz gibt's jetzt.
Katholisch.de, Alter.
Genau, inklusive App.
Da kann man jetzt beten.
Alle hängen geblieben.
Aber okay, ey, jeder wie er will, ja.
Und du hast dann, genau, Click-to-Pray-App gibt's.
Click-to-Pray.
Okay.
Und dann kannst du dir eine App holen.
Und kannst, kannst beten damit.
Exzellent, ja.
Also für alle Gläubigen, die im, die im Jahr 2020 ankommen wollen, die können sich das kaufen, ja.
Ich frag mich, ob's da demnächst nicht auch ein paar Abwandlungen gibt.
Ich mein, das hat ja, das hat ja riesiges Potenzial, ja.
Ähm, du könntest Gebetsteppiche machen, irgendwelche Hütchen oder so, äh, Rosenkränze.
Du kannst ja alles.
Überlegt euch mal so ein eingebauter Gebetsteppich.
Da könntest du einen Kompass einbauen.
Da kannst du das immer, äh, nach Norden, äh, ich weiß nicht in welche Richtung, kannst du den immer richtig ausrichten.
Mit, mit der passenden App dafür.
Äh, da kannst du was, E-Tora, du kannst alles machen.
Du kannst, das hat ja unglaubliches Potenzial.
Du könntest alle, alle Weltreligionen abdecken mit sowas.
Das, das, äh, sowas gibt's.
Es wundert mich nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Wo was zu holen ist, gibt's meistens schon was.
Einstein cracks a joke.
Moment, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Einstein-Joke.
Also, Big, Big Brain.
Also, wenn das kein Big Brain-Joke ist, dann, dann bin ich enttäuscht.
Okay.
Das war nicht lustig.
Das war eher Pains-Cham-Witz.
Vorher, ja.
Damals war es der Schenkelklopfer extrem wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das ist aber ein Trend in letzter Zeit auf YouTube, dass, ähm, und ich weiß nicht, warum, aber es ist ein Trend.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das in letzter Zeit ist, aber Videos werden mir in letzter Zeit empfohlen.
Moment, ich muss mal etwas weniger, etwas weniger, ähm, anstrengende Musik machen.
Ah, excellent.
Ähm, und zwar, in YouTube werden mir in letzter Zeit total viele, so, restaurierte Videos empfohlen.
New York 1905 und solche Dinger.
Oder irgendwie, äh, irgendwelche Rede von irgendwelchen Nazi-Anführern.
Oder, ähm, London, äh, London 1890.
Oder solche Dinger.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr auch so Dinger empfohlen kriegt.
Irgendwelche richtig übelst gut restaurierte Sachen.
Wo du dir denkst, hey, das ist quasi New York 1905 oder so.
Und dann, und dann hast du dann irgendwie, äh, 19, äh, 16 zu 9 Format und, und Farbe.
Richtig krass, wie sie das, wie sie das, äh, restauriert kriegen.
Kriege ich in letzter Zeit total oft empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Äh, das Mafia-Remake habe ich noch nicht angeschaut.
Aber ich weiß nur, dass viele Leute sich wieder sehr über die, äh, Autorenn-Mission freuen.
Kann sich noch einer erinnern an diese Auto, ähm, Car Race?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Die Mission war übelst reudig.
Das habe ich, keine Ahnung, 80 Mal oder so gemacht.
Ja, die war echt schlimm.
Die Mission ist jetzt leichter, okay.
Äh, ich habe, ich habe zufällig bei Dance Gaming reingeguckt letztens.
Und da war gerade die, äh, diese, äh, also zufällig, als diese Mission da war.
Und der hat, keine Ahnung, auch 40 Mal gebraucht oder so.
Oder 30 Mal oder sonst was.
Moin, Kengi.
Hast du Mafia 2 gespielt?
Nee.
Habe ich nicht.
Okay, was gucken wir uns an?
Haben wir noch ein bisschen Video, wo ich über Hardware von anderen Leuten lästern kann?
Nee, How to Mod PS Vita gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Weil das, das steht demnächst bei mir auch, äh, bei mir auch an.
What is up, guys?
Welcome to Tech Savvy Buyer.
So, it has been a while since I put on a latest video.
But hey, I got something cool for you guys.
Out there that have not done this yet.
So, if you have a PlayStation Vita in today's video, I'm gonna teach you how you can modify it so that you can...
Kennst du die Pepo-Animation?
You can play homebrew games on it.
You can expand the storage with a...
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir die on stream flashen können.
Genau weil, weil Monkatos.
Ähm, also, man selbst darf das.
Das ist keine Frage.
Du darfst mit deiner eigenen Hardware in Deutschland glücklicherweise noch machen, was du willst.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das im Stream zeigen darf.
Allerdings, wenn es die ganzen Leute auf YouTube gibt,
ist halt, vielleicht doch okay.
Selbstverständlich werde ich auf meiner geflashten Vita nur Backups von meinen eigenen Spielen spielen.
Also, Chat, wer was anderes denkt, der ist ja auch nicht mehr normal.
Selbstverständlich nur Sicherheitskopien.
Ja.
Ja, ich habe keine PSP mehr.
Wäre es dann im Prinzip nicht schon Monkatos, wenn man das Video hier zeigt?
Kann schon sein, ja.
Schon von dem...
Moment, von was?
Schon von dem MLC...
PC und POS-CAP-Kram bei der RTX9, was ist das?
Ich habe das Fette.
Ja, ich habe...
Oh ne, da muss ich mir eine Vita Memory Card kaufen.
Was kostet denn der Kram?
Wobei, ich habe bestimmt noch eine.
Ich habe bestimmt noch eine Vita Memory Card.
Ernsthaft?
Now, this is a complete noob guide.
This is meant to be super beginner friendly and super user friendly for anyone out there.
Even if you're a professional.
I've been doing this for a while.
This is a really easy way to do it.
And it shouldn't take you more than a few minutes.
Ich habe die Big Brain Idee schlechthin.
Wenn man sich so einen Recording-Raum baut,
man nimmt einfach leere Kisten von Hardware und stellt die sich hier hinten hin.
Da sieht das so aus, als hat man die richtig krasse Hardware-Sammlung hinten stehen.
Dabei sind es einfach nur leere Kisten und die kriegt man bestimmt umsonst.
Oder für ein paar Euro.
Okay, Moment.
Das eBay, eBay.
Ryzen Package.
Ryzen Karton.
Ryzen Verpackung.
Excellent.
So was.
Gucke mal.
Da sparst du dir 400 Euro.
Da sparst du dir 400 Euro und kannst trotzdem im Hintergrund einen Ryzen auf den Schrank stellen.
Excellent.
So machen wir das.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch eine Idee.
Ryzen und danach Preis sortieren.
Preis sortieren.
Wo kann man nach Preis sortieren?
Ah.
Was letzte Preis?
Achso, das sind Aktionen.
Kann man auch sagen, nur sofort?
Nur sofort Kauf?
Tatsächlich.
Na gut.
Aber das wäre doch mal was.
Dann mache ich mir auch so einen coolen Aufnahmeraum.
Das Problem ist nur, ich kann mich ja da nicht hinstellen.
Ich kann mich nicht hinstellen.
eBay Kleinanzeige.
Oh nee, nee, nee.
eBay Kleinanzeigen kaufe ich nichts ein.
eBay Kleinanzeigen, da hast du wirklich die lowbrainigsten Leute der lowbraining.
Also, da ist Rehat nix dagegen.
Also, eBay Kleinanzeigen ist wirklich der allerste Bodensatz unterwegs.
Da kaufe ich nichts ein.
Was letzte Preis?
Und, you know, just a little bit of patience of your time.
But, hey guys, I got your back.
And most likely you're gonna be just fine.
Ja, auf, zeig, wie es funktioniert.
Meine Vita-Firmware ist Release-Firmware, keine Ahnung, mit einem Update.
Wie, warum updaten?
Im Zweifelsfall geht's da nicht mehr.
Und Sheet 95.
Okay, Leute, wir gehen jetzt zum nächsten Schritt.
Also, ihr werdet ein paar File für die Vita brauchen,
um eigentlich ein Modell zu bekommen.
Also, Chat, welcher Desktop ist besser?
Der Desktop oder der Desktop?
Der aufgeräumte.
Was?
Ich find meinen Desktop deutlich schöner.
Vor allem die Windows XP-Wiese.
Und natürlich auch die Icons.
Ich mein, eigentlich ist da noch viel zu viel Platz.
Ich glaub, wir sollten das eher so machen.
Ah, yes.
So ist das gut.
So, wir gehen da jetzt schon.
Wir müssen in die erste Stelle werfen,
die ist der PS Vita Driver, QCMA.
Ich habe einen Link in der Beschreibung.
Ausgesprochen guck mal.
... für diese Website, damit ihr euch kopiert und gespeichert
und folgt dem Tutorial.
Scrollt unten auf executive.
Klickt auf Windows-Installer.
Wenn es sich dannROH tut, geht es an den ersten Filer,
welcher 0,41 ist.
Klickt weiter zu der Installation an.
In der Instruktion.
Da ich bereits das Installer habe,
Ich werde es nicht mit dem Computer durchführen, aber man sieht, dass es sehr einfach ist, es zu installieren.
Sobald wir das installiert haben, werden wir das nächste File downloaden.
Das ist Final HE.
Das kann vom Link in der Beschreibung geliefert werden.
Sobald ihr auf dieser Seite seid, müsst ihr auf den Releases-Tab gehen.
Klickt auf das.
Und ihr solltet Version 1.9.2 downloaden.
Diese ist spezifisch für Support mit 3.7.3.
Ja, man kann wahrscheinlich auch was Neueres nehmen.
Der Hügel sieht anders aus.
Es gab doch letztens ein Bild, wo einer den Windows XP Hügel wieder fotografiert hat.
Der sah jetzt ganz anders aus.
Winrar?
Alter, wir sind im Jahr 2020.
Winrar.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich soll wirklich Winrar installieren.
Monarch S.
7-Zip. Beste.
Mein Ordner würde Ayaya heißen.
Dann freut sich der Chat.
Oder zumindest der Sibaro freut sich.
Chat.
Oh.
Guck mal, läuft.
Okay.
Okay, also die nächste Reihe von Schritten betrifft die Verbindung von Vita zu dem Computer.
Aber bevor du das machst, wollen wir die ganze Software, die wir gerade gedownloadet haben, nutzen.
Also drücke auf FinalHE.exe und bereite fest, dass du...
Es ist immer wichtig in diesen Tutorials, das finde ich immer geil, wenn sie in den Tutorials betonen, dass man auf eine .exe klicken soll.
Als wäre das jetzt was, wo keiner drauf kommen würde.
So nach dem Motto, wenn der einfach nur sagen würde, starte das Programm, würden die Leute sagen, hm...
das Programm, würden die Leute sagen,
hm,
wo geht das zu starten?
Ich finde es nicht, ich finde es nicht. Aber
sagt er, klicke jetzt doppelt auf Programm
Exe, dann, ah, ja, jetzt,
jetzt weiß ich, wie es funktioniert.
Okay,
bis jetzt ist es ja wirklich
komplett
bei Sachen, wenn sie dann den Vita anschließen, ne?
Das kann man in 30 Sekunden machen.
Ach du Scheiße.
So, once we get to this screen, you can see your Vita
has its home screen
pretty much available like that. We're gonna go ahead
and we're gonna click let's go
on the application.
Big Play
Windows Forms UI.
Okay, once complete, you should
see the following screen.
And essentially you're gonna follow
the same instructions that are written
here. So over on our Vita, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna click on copy content
from the PS Vita system
or the PC over to the PS Vita system.
So we're gonna click on that, we're gonna
click on apps,
click on PS Vita, and you're gonna see
H-Encore 2 slide
up there. Go ahead and click that,
click on copy, press
okay.
Now since my Vita already has one
installed on there, it's still okay. Das probier ich nachher
aus. I'm gonna go ahead and
overwrite it just in case. Du musst nur meine Vita finden.
Danach den 3DS
noch flashen.
Copy H-Encore over to your Vita.
Great, now we can go back,
close out of this, disconnect
from your computer.
And as you guys can see, H-Encore
is installed. Go ahead and
click on it, click start,
follow the instructions
with yes.
Was, was, was, was?
Achso.
You cannot earn trophies in this app.
Das musst du Sony einblenden, oder was?
Es ist, es ist, es macht keinen Sinn, Zeit
in diese App zu verschwenden. Du kannst keine
Sachen anloggen. Excellent.
Follow the instructions with yes.
And you should be presented
with this screen. So we're gonna scroll
down and click install in Kaku.
And we're also going to download
Vita Shell.
Wisst ihr was, habt ihr eine Ahnung, was auf der
PS Vita unten drunter für
Betriebssystemen
mäßig was läuft? Also auf der
Playstation ist es, ist es, ist es, ist
glaube ich FreeBSD.
Zumindest ein Teil von FreeBSD
oder Teile von FreeBSD
laufen glaube ich auf der Playstation.
Seit, ich glaube seit der
Playstation 2 schon.
Es könnte sein, dass auf der Vita
auch sowas läuft.
Wikipedia sagt FreeBSD, okay.
Ach guck mal, Moonlighter kannst du sogar
streamsohren.
Now to verify that everything is working correctly
we're gonna go over to our settings.
We're gonna see that we have
Henkaku settings there available now, where
the system update used to be. Go ahead
and click on that and make sure you have PSN
spoofing enabled, make sure you have
unsafe homebrew enabled and make
sure you have version spoofing
enabled as well. Alles klar.
You wanna change the spoofed version
to 3.73. This basically tells Sony's
network every time you connect to it
that you are running firmware 3.73.
So in case. Debated Sony.
Software comes out 3.74. Aber richtig.
You got debated. You can enable the
spoofing version to 3.74. That way you
can still use remote play and all of
the network features of your Vita
without being on the latest firmware.
Sony, debate.
Outplayed.
You guys are pretty much having modified Vita.
This is exactly what it looks like.
Now all these other applications that you
guys are seeing here are not part of
today's video. I will be making.
Okay, das ist ja wirklich einfach.
Ja.
What is the value of having these type of apps on your phone?
But as you can see, you can download a whole bunch of
different games onto your Vita.
Ja, Moment, Moment. Das sind ja
selbstverständlich nur Sicherheitskopien.
Er hat uns doch am Anfang erzählt, dass er, also, ne?
Das müssen Sicherheitskopien sein.
You can actually add a SD Card to it and do a whole
bunch of other cool stuff that make your Vita's life a lot
more longer and a lot more valuable basically.
But guys that's pretty much it.
That's how you hack your Vita.
Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich einfach.
This is actually pretty easy to modify a Vita.
It doesn't take too much time and you get access to
a lot of stuff like I said in the beginning of this video.
So now with that.
If you guys are interested in doing some more cool
things because you actually have a modified Vita,
such as adding an SD card in there or doing any of that,
check out the description below.
Ich habe gute Fragen.
Ich hätte eigentlich fast gedacht, das gibt es von Haus aus.
Netflix gibt es offiziell für die Vita.
Ob das noch geht, ist was anderes.
Okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Windows XP vs. Vista vs. 7 vs. 8 vs. 10 Speedtest.
Wie will man das denn ordentlich vergleichen?
Da müsste man die Dinger ja auch alle auf der gleichen Hardware laufen lassen.
Exzellente Audioqualität.
Gibt es eigentlich ein gutes Spielangebot für die Vita?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich.
Also es gibt ein paar gute Spiele, aber die Sony hat ja keinen Bock auf ihre eigene Konsole gehabt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Also ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Wie gesagt, ich kenne das Video nicht, aber ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Also wenn das hier, warte mal, was ist was?
Das ist XP, das ist 7 und das ist Windows 10.
Nee, Moment.
Das ist 8 und das ist 8.1?
Ach nee, das ist Vista.
Nee, warte mal.
Das ist 7, das ist, Moment, XP, Vista, 7, 8, 1, 10.
Ja?
Also.
Ich denke mal, Windows XP bootet am schnellsten.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist das letzte Service Pack Windows.
Die haben ja mit dem Service Pack extrem viel geändert damals.
Also die haben ja quasi ein komplett neues Windows rausgebracht.
Also ich vermute mal, Windows XP bootet am schnellsten.
Vista war für den Arsch.
Also ich würde sagen, XP bootete am schnellsten gefolgt von Windows 10.
Ich glaube, dass Windows 10 schneller ist als alle anderen außer Windows XP.
Zumindest beim Booten.
Weil Windows XP hat halt kaum was starten müssen damals.
Und war für viel schwächere Hardware gedacht.
Mal gucken.
Aber wie gesagt, ich denke, dass Windows 10 schneller ist als alles, also beim Booten, beim Booten.
Schneller als alle außer XP.
Schauen wir mal.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Okay.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich lag komplett falsch.
So that kind of makes sense.
But after that we have Windows 10.
And literally milliseconds later we have Windows XP.
Followed by Windows Vista a couple of seconds later.
And then a long time afterwards we have Windows 7.
So that's pretty interesting.
It's not 1, 2, 3, 4.
Ich glaube, Leute, ich glaube, das sind keine Flecken.
Ich glaube, das sind Löcher in der Wand.
Also dort, wo da ist einfach der Putz ab.
Oder das ist ein Loch und das ist ein Fleck. Kann natürlich auch sein.
Was ist das jetzt?
Oh, that's pretty interesting.
It's not 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. It's more 3, 4, 5, 1, 2.
Now, before testing programs, I really want to check the storage.
So, as you can see, Windows XP actually takes the least amount of storage.
Von dem Ruf, den sie haben, ist halt, dass die Updates öfters mal schief gehen.
Oh, huge rest. High rest text.
Okay, das ist...
Wahrscheinlich ist der Unterschied ein paar Millisekunden.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wirklich relevant, ja.
So, and results are pretty...
Max, hast du...
Ne, warte, Moment.
Max, du hattest ja OpenSense virtualisiert gehabt.
Hattest du damit Probleme?
Nö.
Es war mir aber zu viel Single Point of Fail, ja, alles auf der gleichen Kiste zu haben.
...varied here.
Moving on to Notepad.
This is probably like the least intensive application in Windows.
Notepad! Oh ja, excellent.
...was the first to load, probably due to the lack of animation.
But again, strangely enough, there are varied results here.
There's probably a percentage error somewhere around here.
But these are really low-end applications.
So I'm not really that surprised that these...
Er könnte ja mal einen aktuellen Browser starten mit 50 Tabs.
Mal gucken, wie lang das dauert.
Oder Photoshop oder so.
Wobei, die gibt's ja gar nicht mehr.
Die gibt's ja alle gar nicht mehr für XP.
Das wird schwierig, da was halbwegs Aktuelles zu vergleichen.
...these applications are running.
There isn't like consistent results here.
But as you can see, Calculator actually loaded up at the exact same time
on every single one except for Windows 8.1.
And that's really weird considering that Windows 8.1 was pretty...
...much winning every other test...
Ja, das liegt daran, dass es eine UWP-App damals schon war.
Dass es eine der ersten UWP-Apps war, vermute ich mal stark.
Und die war halt kacke.
...for this.
So that's pretty strange.
Moving on to Paint.
Again, there really isn't any real answer here.
All the results are pretty varied.
It's really weird that XP and Vista loaded up at the same exact time.
But we probably use Windows for more than built-in programs
and that's media consumption.
So...
...opening a photo using their default photo viewer.
So, as you can see, it was pretty much straight down the line.
Ja, die Foto-App in Windows 10 ist auch einfach kacke.
Und der macht das Foto einfach mal in Paint auf.
...got to run this test on Windows 8.1 because of course I did,
but we can basically assume that it would have been second last.
Then moving on to opening a video using VLC Media Player.
Strangely enough, Windows 7, this was the first time it came first in a test.
Then it was Windows 10, then XP,
and then Vista.
So, strangely enough, these results are also varied.
And also, I decided to use...
Ja, aber das ist alles nicht großartig relevant.
Ich meine, da ist ja kaum Unterschied dazwischen.
...Idee of applications.
Some of them are using same versions.
Auf den Browser-Test bin ich mal gespannt.
So, I decided to use Windows Media Player to open this video file.
And Windows XP and Vista doesn't even support the proper codecs for MP4 files.
But as you can see...
Codec für MP4-Files.
Da muss ich jetzt einmal den Klugscheißer raushängen.
Ich habe es mir schon mal eingelassen.
MP4 ist kein Codec.
MP4 ist der Videocontainer.
Der Codec ist wahrscheinlich H.264.
Oder A.V. ... wie heißt...
Wie ist der offizielle Name von H.264?
A.V. ... nee, äh ...
Oder bring ich es durcheinander?
War H.265?
A.V.C.
A.V.1 ist der neue.
Erstmal...
Crash, Fluffy, erstmal Notizen, genau.
Das ist übelst nice das Emote.
Ich habe das jetzt schon öfters gesehen.
Ich kenne den Channel nicht.
Aber Emotes in dieser Richtung...
Ich muss echt mal wieder auf Fiverr ein paar Emotes kaufen.
End... oder was heißt mal wieder?
Ich muss mal ein paar Emotes kaufen.
Ich habe ja immer noch 20 frei oder so.
Ähm...
Ja.
Also genug Klugscheiß.
Ähm...
Also, MP4 ist kein Codec.
Resultate sind ziemlich ähnlich.
Gehen wir weiter zu Webbrowsern.
Ich möchte wirklich die Installationsgeschwindigkeit von Firefox 52.9 ESR aufschauen.
Natürlich liegt das auf meinen Händen und Reaktionen.
Was?
Firefox läuft noch auf XP?
Ich dachte die haben den Support eingestellt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die ältere Version, ne?
Sind die nicht schon bei 76?
Oder war das Chrome?
Und der Grund warum wir Firefox 52.9 ESR nutzen,
anstatt die späteren Versionen,
weil ältere Versionen die späteren Versionen nicht unterstützen.
Ah ja, genau.
Also, bekannt als die schlechten Operationssysteme
der Öffentlichkeit,
das ist auch ein guter Operationssystem.
Also das ist ziemlich ironisch.
Aber wenn wir den Webbrowser selbst öffnen,
ist es eigentlich komplett anders.
Also, Fiverr ist hier technisch besser.
Windows 10 öffnete erst Firefox,
während Windows XP...
Windows 10, die tricksen aber auch.
Ich glaube die cachen die Programme vorher irgendwie.
Also Windows 10,
die haben irgendwie so eine Big Brain Geschichte,
die Programme quasi
schon so halb startet,
bevor sie gestartet werden,
wenn die oft benutzt werden.
Läuft das überhaupt noch in 51?
Also, Windows 10 könnte vielleicht besser
mit Wifi-Fahrzeugen kompatibel sein,
aber ich bin mir nicht wirklich sicher.
Also, es ist nicht wirklich egal.
Office!
Okay, das unsinnigste Zeug aller Zeiten.
Wer braucht Office?
Und wie ihr sehen könnt,
gab es eine Aktivierung,
während drei von ihnen die neueste Version nutzen.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist nicht Windows Defender,
das ist irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Ich musste viel spedieren,
weil einige davon einen extrem langen Zeitraum benötigen.
Ach ja, ich muss sagen,
ich habe OpenSense nicht unter VirtualBox laufen.
Ich hatte es unter KVM laufen.
Benchmarks!
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Jetzt kommt eigentlich das Interessante noch.
Es macht nicht wirklich viel Unterschied.
Ja, Windows Vista performt am besten.
So...
Überall anders abgeschissen und da jetzt am schnellsten.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Windows XP hat wirklich schlecht performt
und Windows 10 war leider nicht so gut.
Gibt es da irgendwie einen 3D-Mark oder so?
Aber es sollte nicht XP sein.
In meiner Meinung nach.
Na gut, okay.
Eigentlich ein ziemlich sinnloser Test,
aber es geht ganz schön gut dazwischen.
Lass mal downgraden.
Ab zurück zu Windows Vista, genau.
Erst mal die ISO runterladen.
Exzellent.
What?
Warum fängt das Instant an zu downloaden,
ohne dass ich was auswählen muss?
Wobei, warum lade ich das runter?
Das ist total hängen geblieben.
Ich will das eh nicht installieren.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Wie Geldautomaten gehackt werden.
Moment, das hatten wir.
Haben wir hier noch irgendein Hardware-Video?
Ah, excellent.
Ich lässe da doch immer gern über die Hardware von anderen Leuten.
Was, Technikkeller?
Hatten wir von dem irgendwas?
Ist das hier?
Ach, hier.
Der 0-Euro-PC mit gratis Ebay-Teilen.
Okay, das können wir gucken.
Meinst du, es geht klar, einen Server auf dem Dachboden aufzustellen,
sprich wegen Temperatur?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Es kommt drauf an, wie warm es da wird und wie viel Abwärme das Ding produziert.
Aber es sollte eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Die Dinger halten auch ganz gut was aus.
Wie gesagt, ich habe hier ja auch keine...
Ich habe hier ja auch keinerlei Klimageschichten in diesem Raum hier drin.
Und da steht eine 4HE-Kiste, die ist mittlerweile aus.
USB, Switch, Switch, Unity Media, Kabelmodem, Fritzbox.
Hier durch uns rum.
Und das ist auch ein total kleiner Raum ohne jegliche Belüftung.
Bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen, okay.
Was ist der letzte Preis? 0 Euro ist der letzte Preis.
Und ja, ich habe was gefunden in Bühren.
Und ich habe noch 20 Minuten, deswegen wechsle ich eben das Hemd und dann fahre ich hin.
Anzeige, Paket.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich auch auf eBay-Kleinanzeigen nichts kaufen will.
Ich möchte mit den Leuten gar nicht in echt in Kontakt treten.
Da hin, wenn ich einen Screenshot gemacht habe.
Und dann schauen wir uns mal an, was zumindest da drin war, ob das funktioniert und was wir dann sonst so brauchen.
Ja, genau.
Also, ich würde den Server...
Das ist genau richtig.
Was im Chat geschrieben wird.
Also, ich würde den Server nicht in der Ecke stellen, dass du quasi, dass der mehr oder weniger die eigene Abluft wieder einsaugen muss, so nach dem Motto.
Nicht hundertprozentig gemerkt, was da alles dabei war.
Oh, Hi-Hat-Mainboard.
Asus mit PCI-Express.
Ne, äh, sorry, sorry.
Streich das Express mit PCI.
Hat aber gut editiert.
Ah, ich dachte, jetzt gibt es erstmal Dashcam-Crash-Video.
Ja, auf der Rückfahrt soweit keine Probleme.
Eigentlich wollte ich nur dieses Mainboard hier bekommen.
Zeig mal her.
Ne, das ist schon, das ist schon ein PCI-Express.
Das ist kein AGP, das ist schon ein PCI-Express.
Aber das ist ein normaler PCI.
Das PCI... Was ist denn das für eine komische...
Ja, doch, muss es ja gegeben haben, eine Zeit lang.
PCI-Express, einfach. PCI-Express, einfach.
Und wahrscheinlich ein oller 16-fach.
PCI-Express 1, 16-fach.
Und noch drei PCI.
Olle SATA-Anschlüsse, noch einen parallel... äh, einen...
IDE.
USB 2, oder so.
Ja, es gab mal eine Zeit, da war auch USB 1 und 2 blau.
USB, also, USB war schon, war schon ab und zu mal blau, noch bevor USB 3.
Ähm, weil die haben halt einfach gedacht, okay, wir machen alle Slots gleiche Farbe.
ATX, RAM...
Was ist das, Pentium 4?
Ist das, ist das ein Pentium 4?
Also, von dem Lüfter her und dem Zeug, könnte das ein Pentium 4 sein.
Es sieht äußerst oldschool aus, das Board.
Oh, es hat noch DIP-Switche.
...bekommen haben, wie wir vielleicht in dem Bild gesehen haben, sollte da irgendein Core 2 Duo drin sein.
Arbeitsspeicher, weiß ich gar nicht.
Stand drin, es sollte wohl funktionieren.
Genauer habe ich nicht drauf geguckt.
Es ist natürlich zu verschenken.
Schade ist, dass die Blende fehlt, aber die Grafikkarte war auf dem Bild.
Puzzle-Leak.
Eigentlich nicht mit dabei gewesen.
Aber hat er mir trotzdem mit dazu gelegt.
Fakt, hier willst du die abenden.
Ich hatte irgendwie in Erinnerung gehabt, dass hier ein VGA-Anschluss dran ist.
Immerhin optischer Soundausgang.
Allerdings brauchen wir hierfür einen Adapter.
Und, ja, es gibt einen Adapter, der zu verschenken ist, aber das ist ziemlich weit weg.
Und für was, jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört, für was braucht er einen Adapter?
Vielleicht irgendwo mal zwischendurch auf dem Weg, wenn man da einen kleinen Umweg macht, wird sich das wohl lohnen.
Aber ansonsten löte ich da einfach Kabel dran.
Oder ich tue so, als wäre der Adapter zu verschenken.
Keine Ahnung.
Ah Stromadapter.
Jetzt hätte ich ihn abgeholt, weil man hat ja gesehen, ist zu verschenken.
Ich hab da tausend Stück von, also, ne, kosten auch ein, zwei Euro ansonsten.
Aber gut.
Arbeitsspeicher bemisst, oh, zwei Gigabyte.
Na gut.
DDR2.
Na ja, gut.
sich nicht, da kann man ja nicht drüber meckern. Ich meine,
die verschenken ja altes Zeug, ist doch besser, als
in den Müll zu schmeißen. Wenn es nach einer Woche
keine haben will, kann man es ja immer noch wegschmeißen.
Doof. Ich wollte nur dazu...
Aber ich würde es nicht machen, sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Ich würde mein Zeug nicht verschenken, weil
ich habe den Eindruck, dass gerade
auf solchen Plattformen wie eBay Kleinanzeigen
verschenkte Sachen noch
fertigere Leute anziehen.
Also setzt du die Sache für einen Euro
rein, kommen die Leute, die
wirklich wenig Geld haben und es brauchen.
Setzt du die Sachen für umsonst rein,
kommen irgendwelche Volldeppen.
Zumindest ist das so
mein Eindruck, den ich mir, weil ich benutze
die Plattform ja gar nicht,
den ich mir in meinem Kopf
so zurecht male.
Wie gesagt, ich würde es
aus einem anderen Grund nicht einstellen,
weil, wie gesagt, da müsste ich ja mit
echten Menschen in Kontakt treten und die Sachen
übergeben. Das kommt mir nicht
in die Tüte.
...dass ich der Zweite war,
der dieses Ding haben wollte.
Also ich habe dann geschrieben,
so schnell, wie ich das
Angebot gefunden habe,
und da meinte er, ja, jemand anders will das Ding
schon abholen, aber wenn er nicht kommt, dann sage ich dir
Bescheid. Und dann hat er mir heute,
oder besser gesagt, gestern Bescheid gesagt.
Passiert nicht so oft, sage ich mal,
vor allem, wenn es was zu verschenken gibt.
Er sagte mir noch, er hatte das schon,
glaube ich, anderthalb Jahre oder so zu Hause rumstehen.
Irgendwann dann
inseriert für 10 oder 15 Euro,
was ja auch ein total fairer Preis ist, vor allem
für so ein riesiges Mainboard,
oder für ein ATX-Mainboard an sich,
RAM-Riegel, 4x SATA,
IDE ist drauf,
also eigentlich alles, was man braucht
und was das Herz begehrt. Ich schätze
sogar mal,
habe ich eigentlich eine Modellnummer?
Wo ist die?
Zeig dich, versteck dich.
Da oben stand es doch, ja.
Da hier, Stackcool3. Ach ne, da.
Da.
PSP. Unklötige Modellnummer
vielleicht. PSP 410.
Ne, 410.
Ein Asus P5P41D.
Barfuß in solchen Räumen
ist gefährlich. Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
War das nicht sogar mal direkt
im Stream, wo ich mir
so ein
Jumperkabel in die Ferse
gesteckt habe aus Versehen?
Ich glaube, das war
im Stream. Da bin ich rangerutscht
mit dem Stuhl
an den Tisch
und auf einmal hat es
nicht geknallt,
aber hat es
so ein bisschen Batsch gemacht.
Ich hatte das Kabel in der Ferse stecken.
So ein hier.
Man hat ja auf der Ferse
eh schon ein bisschen
härtere Haut und deswegen hat es halt so richtig
gemacht.
Und das hat zwei, drei Sekunden gedauert,
bis es wehgetan hat. Ich habe es so gehört
beim Vorrutschen. Also ich habe mich halt
mit dem Fuß so vorgezogen
auf dem Stuhl, so zum Schreibtisch hin
und hat so gemacht Batsch in die Ferse.
Ich habe gehört, huch, was ist das?
Und zwei, drei Sekunden später habe ich gemerkt,
au!
Au!
Aber es war nicht großartig wild.
Das Problem war nur, es haben zwei, drei Tage
an das Auftreten wehgetan. Danach
war nichts Schlimmes.
Cheat vom Neutsch, das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Manchmal liegt die Wahrheit
eben direkt vor einem. Man sieht sie nur nicht.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich packe noch mal einen Pieper drauf, falls das Ding gleich rummeckert.
Ein vier Zentimeter Nagel
ist schlimmer. Ja, das stimmt.
Es geht immer noch schlimmer.
Aber ich habe wirklich nicht mit gerechnet,
dass ich hier so ein Ding mal in der Ferse stecken habe.
Zumal die auch nicht spitz sind.
Die Kabel, die sind ja eigentlich flach vorn.
Das heißt, du musst da wirklich mit ordentlichem Schmackes
dir das in die Ferse rammen,
dass das auch reingeht.
Strom hat er.
In die Luft gegangen ist noch nichts.
Vielleicht ändert sich das ja.
Oh.
Das ist, das ist exzellent.
Das ist die einzig wahre Methode,
um Mainboards anzuschalten.
So, sehr gut.
Ein guter Mann hier.
Der weiß das.
Der weiß, wie es geht.
Exzellent.
Kurz schließen mit dem Skalpell.
Ich mache das immer mit einem Schraubendreher,
mit einem flachen, aber das ist ja egal.
So ist das gut.
Das vergessen.
Jetzt aber.
Na komm.
Ist das Ding schon so verrostet?
Oh, das hört sich nicht gut an.
Das kenne ich wohl.
Drei Pieps ist die Grafikkarte.
Ach, die wird doch wohl nicht kaputt sein.
Dann ist das ja ein richtig doofes,
Geschenk.
Aber die ist schwer.
Aha.
Hier, Shep drin, Shep drin.
Wir haben einen Core 2 Duo E4300 mit 1,8 Gigahertz.
Nicht der schnellste.
Ja, für umsonst.
Ich finde es eigentlich in Ordnung.
Gut, für geschenkt.
Ja, hat er recht.
Genau.
Die Dinger kosten sonst auch 1, 2 Euro bei Ebay.
Also nichts weltbewegendes, aber immerhin schön, dass es funktioniert.
Genau, also ich meine, es ist wirklich ein lahmes Teil.
Und wer sich jetzt wundert, warum wir nichts hören.
Ich habe den Lüfter mal eben abgeklemmt.
Das war mir ein bisschen zu laut.
Ich glaube, so eine Grafikkarte hatte ich mal auf der Arbeit im Rechner, als ich dort
neu angefangen habe.
Dort, wo ich damals noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, als ich da angefangen habe, hatte ich
so einen ollen Rechner.
Den haben sie damals von Alternate bestellt.
Ja, das war halt noch am Anfang eine ziemlich kleine Klitsche.
Die haben sich quasi Rechner auf Alternate bestellt.
Und ich glaube, da war so eine Grafikkarte drin und der Lüfter war laut as fuck.
Aber das Beste war Wobbly Windows ging unter Linux.
Und Wobbly, also wer es nicht kennt, Wobbly Windows, das ist das wichtigste Feature, was
ihr braucht.
Wobbly Windows.
Hier, Wobbly Windows, Achtung.
Ah, yes, das braucht man.
Wobbly Windows.
Das ist das wichtigste Feature, was ihr braucht.
Das ist das, das ist das allerwichtigste Feature, was man anschalten muss.
Wobbly Windows.
Exquisite.
Und ich habe die so ein bisschen angewinkelt.
Geht unter i3-WM mit PCOM leider nicht und i3 und Compets zusammen funktioniert nicht.
Besser gesagt im rechten Winkel, weil es manchmal sein kann.
Ich kann ja jetzt mal das Ding hier wegnehmen und in diese Richtung schieben, aber hier
bewegt sich noch was.
Ja gut, das ist wirklich gerade nur ein Kontaktproblem gewesen.
Das kann manchmal helfen, wenn man eine Grafikkarte so testet.
Jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich nur noch ein Netzteil und eine Festplatte oder einen USB-Stick.
Dann packen wir da Linux mit einer Live-Version drauf und dann müssen wir immer vom USB-Stick
starten.
Aber wir haben einen PC, der funktioniert.
Ich gucke mal weiter bei eBay.
Das wird jetzt, ich schätze mal, noch zwei Wochen dauern, bis ich alles passende zusammen
habe.
Ich habe gerade mal geschaut.
eBay Kleinanzeigen, Anzeigen auch sortieren nach Preis oder in einer bestimmten Preisspanne
und bei Zuverschenken in der Kategorie PCs oder PC-Teile sind richtig viele Annoncen,
Suche defekte PC-Teile zum Basteln und was weiß ich, bestimmt zehn Stück hier in der
Umgebung.
Da fahren wir ja zwei hin, oder?
Ich hatte kurze Gedanken gefasst, auch eine Annonce reinzupacken, dass ich einfach nur
irgendein Netzteil suche oder irgendeine Festplatte.
Aber dann kommt wahrscheinlich wieder ein Zuschauer auf mich zu.
Er sagt, ja, hier kannst du haben.
Aber das kann man leider nicht auf jeden anwenden und ich will das wirklich so, ja, realitätsgemäß
wie möglich machen.
Ja, wir warten mal.
Wenn es jetzt ein russisches Video wäre, hätten wir jetzt irgendeinen komischen Dashcam-Unfall
gesehen oder keine Ahnung, dass jetzt irgendwie eine Kuh über die Straße läuft und angefahren
wird oder so.
Die russischen Dashcam-Videos sind immer höchst verstörend.
Oder, dass dann irgendwelche Absteckungsdinger überfahren werden und so.
Das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Cheat95, hast du recht.
Wenn du überlegst, was das rumfahren kostet, ist wahrscheinlich PC-Teile bestellen für
ein paar Euro billiger.
Oh, China-Netzteil.
LC Power.
Oh Gott.
Gleich brennt die Busse.
Oh, China-Netzteil.
und ich sehe hier ein 80 plus lc power drauf ich würde behaupten netzteile mit solch einer
zertifizierung sind auf jeden fall nicht die schlechtesten falls es gegenbeispiele gibt
lc power netzteile kaufe ich eigentlich nicht gerne weil man meistens nur die älteren dinger
kriegt aber das hier scheint wohl etwas neuer zu sein und wir haben natürlich auch unseren ja nicht
den hier sondern zeig dich da sechs pin anschluss für unsere grafikkarte ich sehe gerade hier haben
wir dips schalter warum hat hier jemand mit dem edding was drauf gemacht weil es geht ich schließe
es mal eben an dann können wir verifizieren ob es funktioniert oder nein können auch einfach
den netzteiltester verwenden so was gibt es das wäre tatsächlich mal ganz nützlich zu haben und
was kostet so was
ja deswegen gucke ich gerne solche videos dann fällt immer noch ein was man sich so
mal kaufen könnte netzteiltester laggy das ist schon mal ein sehr guter name dafür braucht
doch nie mehr ich finde es eine gute idee das sieht wahnsinnig billig aus und und als machst
du damit sogar das netzteil eher kaputt ich glaube das ist das teilweise wisst ihr was ich speichere
mir das mal kauft gleich zwei um den tester zu testen ist sehr gute idee excel ihr wisst ja ich
kaufe nie ein ich kaufe nie ein netzteiltester ich kauf gleich zwei um den tester zu testen sehr gute idee excel ihr wisst ja ich kaufe nie ein ich
kauf eigentlich mindestens drei allerdings bei solchen sachen eigentlich eher nicht so
kleinen elektronik kram halt davon braucht man keine 3c 500 das haben wir insgesamt 400 watt
das haben wir schon immer gemacht was kosten auf aliexpress okay wenn man sein netzteil wirklich
schrotten will, äh, power, nein, nein, nein, AliExpress, geh, geh weg, supply, test, tester,
ah, excellent, guck mal, das ist das gleiche Ding, vier, vier Euro, okay, das ist bestimmt
absolut high end quality, vier Euro, ach du Kacke, okay, dann ist das, das fackelt wirklich
ab, das ist das, was er hat, okay, aus China, Moment, wo ist, oh, what, äh, Moment, was
für, was für ein Datum ist das, das kommt im, wollen die mir wirklich sagen, aus China
kommt es im Dezember und aus Spanien kommt es in einer Woche ungefähr, 5. Dezember und
aus Spanien, guck mal, das ist ja geil, aus Spanien ist billiger und aus Spanien kommt
das, ist das auch in einer Woche da?
Excellent, Franz, oh, aus Frankreich ist es noch billiger, da kostet der Versand weniger,
ja gut, das, das, der Versand, das ist ja immer so, Versand aus China ist immer, immer
billig, ja, excellent, weil man, du kannst, in China kannst du ja auch sagen, hier irgendwie
was anderes, dann geht es schneller, ähm, das ist ja nur diese Standard AliExpress-Geschichte,
man könnte natürlich auch DHL 8 bis 17 Tage für 57 Euro machen, ne, das ist natürlich
äußerst sinnvoll für so ein Teil.
Frankreich, excellent, so, weitergucken, aber dann ist das Netzteil danach wirklich
im Arsch mit dem China-Ding, kauf nicht zu billig, soll auch funktionieren, ja, wenn
es so, wenn es danach geht, dürfte ich gerade Sachen, wo man, wo man richtig 230 Volt aus
der Steckdose reinmacht, ähm, eigentlich gar nicht testen, also gar nicht verwenden
von AliExpress, mache ich auch ungern, weil das traue ich, ich traue den AliExpress-Teilen
nicht.
Ich, ich traue den nur für irgendwelche...
Ich traue den nur für irgendwelche...
Low-Voltage, äh, Controller-Kram, da kann nichts passieren, großartig.
... nur mal irgendwie 500 stehen und in Wirklichkeit sind es nur 400, ich meine, kann man ja machen,
aber, ne, da denkst du auf den ersten Blick, oh, 500 Watt, ja gut, da gebe ich nur ein
Fünfer mehr für aus, oder dann nehme ich das und dann, oh, sind ja gar keine 500, aber
nun gut, ich habe schon wieder den Anschluss für die Grafikkarte vergessen, so, jetzt
aber, also...
Excellent.
... fliegt noch nichts in die Luft.
Nichts komisches fiepen oder piepsen, zack.
Kommt gleich.
Zur Erinnerung, ich habe den Lüfter bewusst abgestellt.
Gibt gleich Geist auf, LC Power.
Weil er mir gerade noch auf die Nerven gegangen ist, also, vorgestern, als ich das getestet
habe.
Aha, wir kriegen ein Bild, alles klar.
Und ich habe ein Windows 10 USB-Stick mal reingepackt, dann können wir ja sehen, ob
davon irgendetwas bootet, ob die Grafikkarte noch mehr anzeigt als nur BIOS-Zeugs an sich.
Ja, das sieht doch gut aus.
Oh!
Aber mir fällt etwas auf.
Setup!
Ja, das sieht doch gut aus, normalerweise, wenn ich bei irgendeinem älteren PC Windows
installieren möchte.
Haben wir nicht diese Auflösung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er mir die Auflösung anzeigen lassen kann.
Ich lasse es besser mal, weil wenn man da irgendwas drückt, dann aktiviert er irgendwelche
Power-Spar-Modi und so und das ist voll komisch.
Also, der ist, der habe ich mal geschenkt bekommen, den Monitor.
Und man sieht auch, der ist hier kaputt, aber zum Testen reicht er hier eben.
Exzellent.
Und ja, der ist auch ein bisschen verwirrt eigentlich.
Als ich ihn bekam, sollte er nur manchmal eingeschaltet werden können.
Das lag dann aber an dieser Power-Spar-Modi.
Ja, dann brauchen wir noch ein Gehäuse und eine Platte des Festes.
Okay, Gehäuse, Gehäuse bei eBay Kleinanzeigen für 0 Euro.
Die sind wahrscheinlich sowas von dreckig, die musst du erstmal in die Desinfektions-,
erstmal wahrscheinlich in die Waschstraße fahren, das Gehäuse, dass du das überhaupt
anfassen kannst.
Und dann einmal in Desinfektionsmittel tauchen.
Es ist nun der nächste Tag und heute hole ich ein Gehäuse.
Mit SD-Kartenleser und CD-Laufwerk ab aus Amstetten.
Natürlich auch zu verschenken.
Abkärchern, ja, das könnte man machen.
Das packe ich mal hier hin.
Ist nichts Besonderes.
Ich glaube, da sind noch ein paar Kabel dabei.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Ich fahre hin.
Und er meinte, er stelle es einfach nur vor die Tür.
Vielleicht aufgrund von Corona, vielleicht auch nur so, weil er sich nicht zeigen möchte.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So würde ich das auch machen.
Da muss man mit den Leuten nicht interagieren.
Keine Ahnung.
Nein, das ist wahrscheinlich Corona.
Ey.
Ist einem schon mal diese Lampe?
Ja, aufgefallen.
Irgendjemand hatte letztes Mal geschrieben, hängt da Socken an der Decke oder so.
Nee, das ist einfach nur eine Lampe.
Das ist von Ali.
Das sieht original aus wie so eine AliExpress-Lampe.
Ey, das sieht gar nicht so dreckig aus.
Das sieht brauchbar aus.
Mal innen reingucken, mal innen reingucken.
Das ist unser wunderschönes Gehäuse.
Windows XP, alles klar, okay.
Hier unten haben wir einen USB-Anschluss.
Der andere wurde rausgerubbt, übergeklebt oder so.
Hier haben wir noch einen Lizenzaufkleber für irgendwas von Microsoft.
Steht da nicht mehr drauf, was es genau ist.
Kann man das aufmachen?
Oh.
Ah, ja, okay.
Das ist schön.
Ein altes Floppy-Laufwerk.
Na gut.
Sieht doch gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Bisschen Staub halt drin.
Vergelbte Kabel.
Es ist, je nachdem wie alt das ist, auch normal.
Alles IDE-Gedöns.
Das Ding vorher mal gestanden hat.
Aber ein SATA-Laufwerk.
Sogar DVD.
Man hat schon gedacht, so ein CD, okay, CD-Laufwerk, muss ja schon richtig alt sein.
Dann würde ich vorschlagen, das mal sauber zu machen.
Aber das hier drin, bis auf so ein bisschen sauber machen, kannst du da nicht viel machen.
Das stand wahrscheinlich eine Weile dann irgendwo im Garten oder sowas.
So auch.
Ja, ich versuche mal mein bestes Kleb, das hier noch.
Bisschen saugen.
Tatsächlich.
Weil des Öfteren schon gefragt wurde, wie und womit ich PCs und Teile reinige,
empfehle ich einfach mal mein Video zu diesem Thema, das jetzt oben rechts verlinkt sein sollte.
Trotzdem habe ich aber noch einige Anmerkungen.
Alte Wärmeleitpaste entferne ich immer mit Bremsenreiniger, welcher zuvor auf ein Tuch gesprüht wurde.
Isopropanol, Alkohol oder...
PK-Onkel Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Huge Subscription.
Es gibt sogar spezielle Reiniger nur für Wärmeleitpaste.
Um jegliche Bauteile wieder etwas Glanz zu verleihen,
verwende ich zunächst einen Pinsel oder das Luftgebläse, den Lüster, für Staub.
Der Lüster.
Ich füge zudem ein Taschentuch mit Silikonspray ein und verreibe das dann auf den meisten Plastikteilen
und meistens auch auf den Plastikteilen.
Auf die freien Stellen des Mainboards.
Bitte aber nicht wild mit einem Pinsel oder Tuch 500 Mal über das Mainboard scheuern.
Dabei besteht nämlich die Gefahr der elektrostatischen Aufladung.
Und das killt dann euer Mainboard.
By the way, Leute.
Ich habe jetzt ein Antistatik-Armband.
Nach über 25 Jahren PC-Gebastel,
habe ich jetzt auch so einen ESD...
ESD-Armband.
Besser spät als nie, ja.
Und nicht wireless.
Braucht man das?
Also ich habe es 25 Jahre nicht gebraucht und es ist mir nie was kaputt gegangen.
Aber gerade bei so Microcontroller-Kram,
wo ich ja in letzter Zeit viel damit mache,
habe ich mir gedacht, keine schlechte Idee,
sowas zu haben, weil die Dinger sind halt relativ schnell mal rip.
Kann euer Mainboard killen.
Also bitte nur drei oder vier Male komplett drüber
und damit den Bebläse, den Rest,
abhusten.
Die Plastikteile oder Kühler können jedoch gefahrlos mehrmals abgeputzt werden,
meiner Meinung nach.
Wenn der Kühler flüssig...
20 bis 25 Jahre?
Nee, ich bin, ich bin...
Achso, nee, Moment.
Wie alt bin ich?
Ich bin...
36.
Ja.
Mit elf?
Mit elf...
Das kann durchaus sein, dass ich mit elf
ähm...
an der ersten Technik-Sachen schon ein bisschen rumgeschraubt habe.
Das kann man die meisten Modelle vom Lüfter befreien
und entsprechend mit einem Pinsel, Tuch oder Gebläse
die einzelnen Lamellen reinigen.
Ob man überhaupt die neue Wärmeleitpaste braucht?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich ist die alte schon total, ähm, porös.
Moin, Ehax.
36 Stimmen immer noch wie 16. Ja, irgendwann ist vorbei.
Ich habe mich schon damit abgefunden, dass ich keine
ultramännliche, äh, Bassstimme mehr bekomme.
Ich habe mich schon damit abgefunden, dass ich keine ultramännliche, äh, Bassstimme mehr bekomme.
Was auf YouTube viele versuchen da auch irgendwie zu kaschieren, ne?
Ich habe schon Leute gesehen, die dann so einen Filter drin haben,
die absichtlich tiefer reden und dann noch einen Filter drin haben,
die dann quasi sagen
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
So, nach dem Wort. Das klingt dann übelst gefakt und schlecht.
... Schrauben nicht lösen lassen,
erhitzt ihn ein wenig mit einem Haarfön.
Das wirkt tatsächlich Wunder.
Ist der Kühler dann mal entfernt
und die alte Wärmeleitpaste wirklich steinhart,
bitte ich darum, die harte Paste nur
mit so Plastikstückchen zu entfernen.
Das zerkratzt dann nämlich sonst die Kühlfläche,
wenn man da ein Messer oder ein Schraubenzieher für verwendet.
Nein, nein, nein.
Man macht das der Bauer-Style.
Der Auer, der verwendet
immer Rasierklingen dafür.
Also, wenn man auch so
stylisch sein will, macht man Wärmeleitpaste
und alles nur noch mit Rasierklingen ab.
Schraubendreher, Bremsereiniger,
Alkohol, ja,
sowohl als auch.
Kühlspray, neue Wärmeleitpaste,
eventuell noch neue Wärmeleitpads,
wenn die zu ersetzen sind.
So ein Plastikspachtel.
Und das geht jetzt für 0 Euro?
Also für 0 Euro fährt man
quasi erstmal irgendwie
80 Kilometer für ein Kabel
und die Wärmeleitpaste,
die hat man dann aber zufälligerweise
noch im Schrank liegen.
Ich meine, das Projekt ist cool, aber
ein bisschen inkonsistent ist das
jetzt an der Stelle schon.
Man kann es auch für Schrauben,
Taschentücher oder vielleicht ein altes T-Shirt,
was man sowieso wegschmeißen würde,
wenn man das Gehäuse sauber macht.
Und diese Plastikspachtel, das sind
die Dinger, die man immer dazu bekommt,
wenn man jetzt beispielsweise ein
Ersatzdisplay oder so für ein Handy bestellt.
Genau diese Dinger, meine ich,
die sind hart genug.
Man kann auch Zahnpasta nehmen.
Ich habe mal irgendwo einen Test gesehen,
wo es Leute mit Zahnpasta ausprobiert haben
und das ging tatsächlich ganz gut.
Und die haben das dann auch so beschrieben,
der ganze Raum würde quasi
erfrischend nach Minze riechen,
wenn man Wärmeleitpaste als
wenn man Zahnpasta als Wärmeleitpaste nimmt.
Sockelabdeckung
vom Mainboard,
die sind auch hart genug
und zerkratzen eigentlich nichts.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt hier sowas denken wie
ja, sieht ja wohl anders aus als vorher,
aber nee, ist tatsächlich gar nicht so,
weil das Gehäuse
Ist halt ein bisschen dreckig,
aber das stört doch nicht.
Die Kabel sind gelb, da kannst du auch nicht großartig
gegen machen,
jetzt müsstest du wahrscheinlich einen halben Tag
mit Alkohol irgendwie abreiben.
Bei vergelbten Plastikteilen
habe ich ein Video gesehen,
der hat die in irgendeine
boah frag mich nicht mehr,
in irgendeine Lösung eingelegt
und dann war Andi wieder weiß.
Socken als Wärmeleitpaste
E-Axis hat
auf die Idee bin ich noch nicht gekommen.
Hat schon gesagt, dass irgendwas fest ist,
Korrosion, irgendwas in der Art,
dass die Füße noch da sind.
Es glänzt ein wenig mehr an den passenden Stellen.
Ich habe ein paar Aufkleber entfernt da oben.
Hier war noch irgendwie so ein Rest drin.
Ja, hier sind eine ganze Menge
Kratzer drauf. Normalerweise wäre das jetzt
irgendwie ein besseres Gehäuse mit Seitenfenster,
Beleuchtung, Lüfter, was weiß ich.
Bei den Kratzern würde ich dann vorschlagen,
da mit einer Spraydose drüber zu gehen.
Jetzt einmal und morgen.
Also mal wirklich, wenn man 0 Euro PC
zusammenbaut, ist doch okay, wenn das Gehäuse
ein bisschen schäbig aussieht am Ende. Ist egal.
Hauptsache es passt alles rein und es funktioniert.
Die Frage ist nur, weil hier auch schon
was steht, da etwas passt nicht,
ob der Kram ins Gehäuse passt, den er da so hat.
Normalerweise müsste er es.
Das war ein ganz normales ATX Mainboard.
Aber gerade günstige Gehäuse
haben da manchmal so ein bisschen
Spielraum.
Nochmal oder ein paar Stunden, damit man die nicht
mehr so ganz stark sieht. Aber hier macht das absolut
keinen Sinn. Ich meine, guck dir mal die Kabel an.
Ich krieg sie auf jeden Fall so nicht sauber.
Genauso wie der Rest des Gehäuses.
Jedenfalls stinkt es jetzt nicht mehr so nach alten Gehäusen.
Und wir können den PC
weiter zusammenbauen.
Als ich gerade dazu kam, das einzubauen,
ist mir dann eine Sache aufgefallen.
Ich hab vorhin schon beim
sauber machen so ein bisschen argwöhnisch hier so reingeguckt
und dann auf das Mainboard wieder zurück.
Passt nicht.
Das ist ein ATX Mainboard
und das ist ein Mikro ATX Gehäuse.
Oh!
Passt nicht.
Wahrscheinlich würde es irgendjemand sogar vorschlagen,
der dann absolut keine Ahnung hat.
Ist dann ja auch nicht so schlimm.
Dann funktioniert das Mainboard nicht mehr.
Einfach absteigen.
Abflexen.
Traurig aber war, entweder benötigen wir ein neues Mainboard
oder ein neues Gehäuse.
Ein neues Gehäuse.
Oder gar kein Gehäuse.
Einfach alles auf den Karton stellen.
Ja.
Und es ist jetzt ja auch leider nicht so,
dass wir einfach sagen können,
ja holen wir uns hier ein neues Gehäuse da.
Das wird wahrscheinlich sogar passen.
So ein hässliches...
Bei dem wird es schwierig.
Müsste man nachfragen.
Fünf Euro kosten die Dinger normalerweise.
Aber das geht in diesem Falle nicht.
Wir können jetzt natürlich auch cheaten und sagen,
ja eine Festplatte habe ich ja schon mal zugeschickt bekommen
von einem Zuschauer.
Oder ich nehme einfach irgendein anderes Gehäuse,
was ich nicht mehr brauche.
Passt nicht.
Geht leider nicht.
Wir sehen uns dann in 2023.
Das hätte er sich vielleicht vorher angehört,
wenn er es nicht sauber machen muss.
Na gut.
Man kann...
Manchmal hat man einfach Pech.
Die Zeiteinschätzung ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Zwei bis drei Wochen hat es gedauert,
bis sich was anderes passen ist.
Ach du Scheiße, zwei bis drei Wochen.
Okay, das ist aber wirklich nur für die absoluten
Low-End-Leute,
die wirklich nichts ausgeben wollen.
Erstmal die Bierflasche,
die mir dann kommt.
Was ich jedoch tun werde,
weil ich noch so viel zu erzählen habe
und weil es mir einfach zeitlich besser in den Kram passt.
Da vorne steht jetzt was,
aber ich hätte es so nicht erwartet.
Ihr könnt ja mal
zum nächsten Part, der kommt in den nächsten paar Tagen.
Ich denke mal das nächste Video was kommt.
Wo ist der nächste Part?
Schreibt mal, ob ihr das erwartet hättet
oder vielleicht irgendwie auch nicht
oder gar nichts oder so.
Ja gut.
Ich bedanke mich dann recht herzlich für's Zuschauen.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns zum nächsten Part wieder
oder auch nicht.
Den nächsten Part, den muss ich mir jetzt noch geben.
Ja, 0 Euro PC ist gratis eBay-Teil.
Exzellent.
Hey und willkommen zurück zu einem neuen Video von mir.
Heute geht's weiter mit Part 2 zu der 0 Euro PC
aus gratis eBay-Teilen.
Hatte ja gesagt, es gibt zwei Teile
und deswegen werde ich gleich auch ganz
Jump-Cut-mäßig ins eigentliche Video wieder einsteigen.
Ich empfehle den ersten Teil
hier zugesehen zu haben,
damit man auch ein bisschen versteht, was ich hier,
oder man versteht wahrscheinlich, was ich vorhabe,
aber dann weiß man, was ich vorher schon getan habe.
Damit das Ganze hier so klappt, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Also, wir springen mal eben ein paar Tage zurück.
Ich habe zwei Sachen gefunden.
Einmal ein Gehäuse aus Münster
und eine Festplatte aus
Lingen. Oder besser gesagt
Ah, Lingen. Weltstadt Lingen.
Keine Ahnung, wo das ist. Festplatten.
Und ich habe den eigentlich nur gefragt, ob er mir die beste daraus geben kann.
Weil ich nämlich bei eBay
eine Annonce geschaltet habe, wenn jemand eine
Festplatte zu verschenken hat.
Dann nehme ich die gerne. Habe aber extra dazu
geschrieben, dass es niemand sein soll, der mich kennt,
damit ich da keinen Vorteil oder
sowas in der Art habe.
Und in einer Minute muss ich losfahren,
damit ich pünktlich ankomme, also
soll ich diesmal tun.
Diesmal nehmen wir den Golf mit.
Du kommst aus Lingen, okay.
Wir müssen ja gleich einen vernünftigen Zeitraffer haben, ne.
Echt immer warm.
Das ist eine SG4000.
Habe ich mal für 40 Euro oder so gekauft.
Aber ich glaube, irgendwann brauche ich mal hier
eine andere Actioncamp für Zeitrafferzeug.
Na ja, mal schauen.
...
Ich mein, man hatte
Früher hatte man sich immer
Big Tower gekauft, immer
Und man hat im Endeffekt nichts
Eingebaut
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, meine ersten Rechner
Außer der allererste, der allererste war auch so ein
Midi Tower
Die Rechner danach waren alle
Big Tower, immer
Und jetzt kaufe ich ja nur noch diese
Fractal Design Dinger
Das sind ja eigentlich Midi Tower
Aber eigentlich sind die auch ziemlich geräumig
Die R4, R5, R6
Und die Fein
Das ist huge fett
Ja, richtig fettes Teil
Sogar mit Lüfter nebendran
Und wahrscheinlich
Wenn der Glück hat, sogar
Ähm
Filter
Staubfilter
Äh, wenn ich das Ding jetzt aufmache, fällt mir wahrscheinlich alles entgegen
Das mache ich gleich nach einem Schnitt
Und die Festplatte habe ich gerade abgeholt
Aus Lingen, das war das letzte Eck
Von Lingen, habe ich das Gefühl
Er meinte auch noch, ja, da sind vielleicht noch Daten drauf
Also, die muss ich dann
Okay, also ganz ehrlich, bevor ich eine Festplatte verschenken würde
Das erste, also das letzte, was ich noch machen würde
Ist, einmal das Ding mit Nullen
Dedehnen
Löschen, also habe ich jetzt kein Problem mit
Dass ich die löschen muss, aber das sollte man
Generell vorher immer tun
Vielleicht ist das doch der Grund, warum Festplatten allgemein nicht verschenkt werden
Weil man entweder keine Lust hat
Die zu löschen, vielleicht auch sicher zu löschen
Oder sich dann wirklich nochmal
Äh, die halbe Stunde Zeit
Nehmen im Internet, wie man die dann wirklich komplett
Mit Nullen und Einsen überschreitet
Was sind das eigentlich für Platten, haben wir da irgendwie ein bisschen Auflösung
Dass man das erkennt
Habe ich gerade abgeholt, aus Lingen
Was ist denn das, ich erkenne das nicht, WD
WD, was
25, 250
Das war das letzte Eck von Lingen
Habe ich das Gefühl
Die halbe Stunde Zeit nehmen im Internet
Wie man die dann wirklich komplett
Mit Nullen und Einsen überschreibt und so weiter
Und dann die Zeit, die das noch braucht
Naja, und dann meinte er noch, er hätte noch was anderes
Gehabt, was er irgendwie wegschmeißen wollte
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja komm, nehme ich mit
Das ist ein Xeon
X3330
4x2,66
Wenn der Glück hat
Passt das sogar
Es gab ja ein paar Xeons
Die in Desktop Mainboards gepasst haben
Aber
Den gleichen Socklatten
Ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren auch mal einen Desktop Xeon
Und weil das Mainboard
Was ich ja jetzt schon habe
Sockl 775 ist, kann man da vielleicht
771 Mod
Kann man sich mit Sicherheit auch selber bauen
Keine Ahnung
Mit dem Tesa Streifen
Da könnte man die CPU vielleicht auch verwenden
Es bleibt spannend
So und ich sehe hier gerade, das ist eine
Western Digital Raptor
Und ich glaube die Platten, die sind etwas schneller
Das waren die 10.000er
Die Raptors, damals waren die mit 10.000 oder 15.000 Umdrehungen
Ich weiß nicht mehr, die waren
Zu Zeiten, wo es auch keine SSDs gab
Hatten die ganzen High-End Gaming-PCs
Hatten den Krams drin
Ich weiß es aber nicht
Da ist ein Acer-Aufkleber von 2008 drauf
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Smart-Werte davon aussehen
Aber am meisten interessiert mich jetzt
Was da noch dabei gewesen ist
Das werde ich einmal hier
Der Hintergrund ist manchmal blau
Und manchmal schwarz
Und manchmal hat der auch einen epileptischen Anfall
Dass diese Blasen dann...
Super schnell sind
Also wirklich richtig, richtig schnell
Was soll das?
Der Inhalt der Tüte mit PC-Teilen enthielt neben Kleinteilen folgendes
Ein 460 Watt Sharkoon-Netzteil
Ok, ok
LC-Power kann nach Hause gehen
Also ich würde lieber dieses Sharkoon-Netzteil reinbauen
Als das LC-Power
Es könnte natürlich sein, dass das Sharkoon-Netzteil auch ein LC-Power ist
Und einfach Sharkoon drüber geklebt ist
Ein Sockel 775er Board
Mit 3 GHz-Core, 2 Duo und 4 GB RAM
Eine uralte Grafikkarte, die vermutlich vormals mit dem grünen 775er Board betrieben wurde
SATA und IDE-Kabel, sowie ein ASRock Z68 Mainboard für Sockel 1155
Das wäre sogar viel besser als das andere
Das 775er Board funktioniert, allerdings sind die Halterungen für die RAM-Riegel abgebrochen
Das Netzteil schaltet ein, beim Netzteil-Tester fehlt jedoch das Power-Good-Signal
Das eine Mainboard wäre viel besser als das andere, was er schon hat, oder?
...sind jedoch on point in ihrer Toleranz, was mich vermuten lässt, dass es selbiges Signal in älteren Netzteilen noch nicht gibt
Wie ich da falsch? Eine kurze Google-Suche hat mir da leider nicht geholfen
Natürlich will ich jetzt noch wissen, ob das Board funktioniert
Ja, das wäre nämlich viel besser
Ich habe jetzt einfach nur einen älteren i5 draufgepackt
So, einmal aus und dann wieder an, das wäre gut
Wow!
Ah, ich habe kein Pipa angeschlossen
Ja gut, das ist mehr als eindeutig
Dann suchen wir uns hier mal den Slot 1 raus
Das bist nämlich du
Beispatterie habe ich gerade einmal rausgehabt
So, dann nochmal an mit dir
Aha, wir kriegen ein Bild
i5, mhm
Ja, das ist schon mal DEUTLICH besser als das andere
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel, was hier drin ist
Jo, das ist doch schön
Nö
Ihr wisst gar nicht, warum ich mich so freue über das Mainboard, ne?
Aber die Z-Varianten, die kannst du zum Übertakten verwenden
Ich kann ja mal schauen, ob jemand genau das hier verkauft
Ich wette, das sind mindestens 40 Euro
Ach, guck es dir an
Eine Windows-7-Home-Premium-Lizenz ist auch dabei
Von was?
Das sorgenfreie Gehäuse, ich weiß gar nicht, womit ich das verdient habe
Wohlan
Es ist nun der nächste Tag, ich komme gerade von Chiara, es ist 9 Uhr oder so, keine Ahnung
Erklärt auch die Jahre
Ich habe auch nicht geduscht oder so
Aber ich mache mich wahrscheinlich gleich eh dreckig
Ich mache jetzt das Gehäuse sauber, räume hier den Kram weg und baue dann...
Achso, der i5 war da gar nicht dabei
Achso, achso
Wir hören uns gleich nochmal
Ich bin übrigens positiv überrascht, wie verhältnismäßig sauber das Gehäuse eigentlich war
Einmal mit dem Pinsel durch, die Fort- und Staubfilter gereinigt und mit Silikon spray die schwarze Farbe hervorgehoben
Oh, es wird sogar noch hier gesprayt
Hehehe, nein, nein, nein
Das ist Technikkeller
Guck ihn dir an, das ist der Knochen oder Hobel
Ich meine, passt doch ganz gut
Oder wie auch immer man das Ding letztendlich nennen möchte
Und das war, also die längste Zeit, wo ich PC Zeug bastel, hat man nicht auf den Style großartig geachtet
Also nicht nur man selbst als Bauer, sondern auch die Hersteller
Da waren die Mainboards waren braun mit braunen Dingern, blauen Sachen, rote Grafikkarten, gelbe Kabel, blaue Kabel, grüne Kabel, weiße Kabel
Alle, alle möglichen Dinger
Das sah einfach so zirkusmäßig aus früher im PC
So komplett, komplett durcheinander
Es gab schon immer die ein oder andere Leute, die halt versucht haben das zusammen zu passen, zu stylen, ja ok
Aber die längste Zeit, wo ich mich erinnern kann, sahen PCs tatsächlich so aus innen drinne
Dann und dann noch irgendwelche komischen IDE Kabel in blau oder grau oder sonst wie
Das ist eher so die letzten 6, 7 Jahre, wenn es hoch kommt
Wo die Sachen deutlich stylischer und designter aussehen
Ja gut, Kabelmanagement hat da ja auch keiner so richtig gemacht
Das höchste der Gefühle an Kabelmanagement war, dass man die Kabel vielleicht mal hierdurch gemacht hat
Oder aber zusammengebunden hat mit zwei Kabelbindern
Ich habe jetzt erstmal nur eine SSD von mir dran gepackt
Damit wir die Festplatten einmal überprüfen können, welche davon am besten ist
Damit wir sie verwenden können
Was machen wir mit diesem Teil, habe ich von einem Zuschauer bekommen
Weil ich irgendwann mal gesagt habe, ja ich muss mir so ein Ding nochmal bestellen
Das vergesse ich immer und da hat er mir das zugeschickt
Tadaaa
Lüfter hören ist schonmal gut
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, was für eine Windows-Installation da drauf war
Oh, wir sehen auch nichts
So, ja logisch, dass wir nichts sehen
Ich habe natürlich mal wieder vergessen
Das passiert mir immer bei solchen alten Karten
Diesen Stromstecker hier anzuschließen
Dürft ihr auch nicht vergessen, sonst passiert ja wieder gar nichts
Oder das Ding sagt euch bei jedem Starten
Ja bitte Stromkabel anschließen, sonst gibt es kein Bild, ist ja logisch
Ich habe die Festplatten jetzt alle mal getestet
Und die Smartwerte sind in Ordnung
Und Betriebsstunden
Diese Platte hier mit 250 GB hat 30.000 Betriebsstunden
Aber der Rest so 3000, 7000 und 7000
Und ich habe mich nicht geirrt, die Raptor-Platten sind tatsächlich ein bisschen schneller
Ich habe vor längerer Zeit mal diese üblichen Western Digital blau und grünen Festplatten getestet
Was diese für Lese-Schreibgeschwindigkeiten haben
Und da sind wir ungefähr bei 100 MB pro Sekunde
Und laut einem Test
Geht, geht doch
Auf dieser Webseite hier
HD-Tach
Sagt er hier 135 MB pro Sekunde
Die Raptor-Dinger waren der geilste Shit hier, was Festplatten angeht
So pre-SSD-Ära
Das bedeutet
Weil die ja auch nicht, also die ist zwar alt, aber 7000 Stunden ist ja nichts
Also bei 30.000 Stunden, 35, muss man sich langsam mal eine neue besorgen
Die gehen nicht von dem einen auf den anderen Tag kaputt, auf gar keinen Fall
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, packe ich die Festplatte mal dort hinein
Und dann installiere ich Windows 7
Weil ich ja zum einen etwas ältere Hardware hier habe
Klar, Windows 10 wird auch klappen, aber ich habe einen passenden Lizenz-Code
Und ich denke mal, dass es hier auch besser wird
Ist Windows 7 eigentlich noch supported?
Ne, oder?
Ist jetzt komplett ausgelaufen, ne?
Aber noch, aber noch gar nicht so lange, oder?
Ah hier, Januar 20, wollte ich gerade sagen, so lange ist das nämlich noch gar nicht her
Ja
Dann ist vorbei
Gibt
Ich habe gerade mal die Arbeitsspeicher durchgetestet, die dabei waren
Moin Hack&Code
Und die haben 2x 2GB
Ja, also das war mir nämlich so im Hinterkopf, dass es noch gar nicht so lange her ist
Die haben 2x 1GB
Nur funktionieren die 2GB-Dinger nicht zusammen mit den 1GB-Dingern
Das heißt, die können wir
Das, das
Kösch der Hasengebern
Ich habe es leider wieder vergessen, es hat nicht mal jemand berichtet, wie es heißt
Ich habe es extra nochmal rausgesucht
Marius hat gesagt, das Korsch der Hasegeber
Der Hasageber
Das Korsch der Hasageber
Was?
Lernen wir auf jeden Fall noch
Schwäbisch, ja
Hier haben wir noch eine Sache, die relativ wenige Menschen betreffen sollte
Wenn man sich ein billiges Gehäuse kauft von Ebay
Hat man manchmal beim Frontpanelanschluss hierfür die Kopfhörer
Kein HD-Audio, so wie es hier der Fall ist, sondern AC97
Ich habe jetzt nur AC97 genommen
Weil das Kabel dann ein Stück länger ist
Und weil das dann nicht so runter hängt
Ich meine, das ist kein Kabelmanagement, aber es ist ein altes Gehäuse
Hinten kannst du nicht
Ist AC97 nicht der Audiochip?
Also, okay
Wenn die allzu viele Kabel lang führen und diese Kabel erst recht nicht
Weil die dann nur bis hier irgendwo so gehen
Und das passt dann alles nicht
Und deswegen, ne
Dann muss man, wenn man es findet, das kann man nicht
Achso, dann kann man auswählen
Den Frontpanel-Controller auf AC97 umstellen
Der Unterschied besteht darin
Dass bei AC97 vorne in der Buchse kein Sensor drin steckt
Der dem Mainboard und dem Audio-Controller sagt
Yo, hör mal, hier hinten, da kommt jetzt nichts mehr raus
Wir haben vorne mal angeschlossen
Gib gefälligst da was aus
So, und bei AC97 wird das einfach durchgängig nach vorne und nach hinten durchgeschleust
So wie ich es verstanden habe, korrigiert mich
Wenn es falsch ist
Kein Schimmer
Das sind noch die
Das ist noch richtiges Oldschool-Bio-Gerät
Nichts Maus-Unterstützung
Nichts Online-Update
Einfach so ein ganz puppliges, normales, blaues
Ist das schon ein EFI-Bio?
Nein, ist das nicht
Aber hier oben mit fancy Animationen
Vielleicht müssen wir das noch machen für die Xeon-CPU
Jedenfalls habe ich hier gerade noch, weil in den vorderen Teilen einer gefehlt hat
Das DVD-Laufwerk aus dem letzten Gehäuse hinein gepackt
Also, hat es nicht geklappt
Hat sich das doch ein bisschen gelohnt
Und es ist bei diesem Gehäuse tatsächlich richtig cool
Man muss nämlich, wenn man irgendwelche Sachen einbauen will
Das so machen
Dann kann man das Bauteil hineinschieben
Da ist so eine Plastikschiene dabei
Und wenn das Ding dann drin ist
Ja, das ist gut
Das war, also früher war Gehäuse-Schrauben echt
Richtig abartig
Du musstest teilweise alles ausbauen, dass du irgendwelche Teile ändern konntest
Da haben die heute deutlich bessere
Big-Brain-Design-Geschichten
Dann ist das fest
Also wirklich sehr schönes Design
Wer es noch extra sichern möchte oder diese Dinger nicht hat
Kann natürlich auch Schrauben verwenden
Ach, wie ich das vermisst habe
Schon so lange kein Windows 7 mehr installiert
Ich durfte gerade erstmal den License-Key eingeben
Super, ne?
Normalerweise klappt das auch bei gebrauchten Mainboards immer zack
Also Windows 7
Was ich an Windows 7 mochte ist
Dass man es total einfach anlocken konnte
Man musste sich nämlich einfach nur
Einen, äh
Einen
Okay, vielleicht
Gebe ich jetzt besser da keine
Ich will jetzt ja nicht so viel MonkaTos erzählen
Weil man weiß ja nie, was da so alles erlaubt ist
Auf Twitch
Ähm
Custom-Bootloader
Mit OEM-Zertifikat drinne
Und instant verunlockt
Ohne Key, ohne alles
Hatte man eine Lizenz?
Hatte man eine Lizenz
Und die konnten das auch nicht mehr
Die konnten das auch nie wieder zurückrufen quasi
Weil dann wären ja echte PCs ausgefallen
Also können wir die weiterverwenden
Klappt in den allermeisten Fällen
Über Neenight installiere ich jetzt mal ein paar Programme
Die man gebrauchen kann
Macht der automatisch Chrome, Firefox, Audacity
Audacity
Open Office und so eine Geschichten
Wer auf der Suche nach Treibern ist
Wird sie auf der Herstellerseite kriegen
Ich werde tatsächlich immer noch gefragt
Wir geben ein
Asus P5P41D
Und landen dann auf der Asus Seite
Exzellent
Und dort gehen wir dann oben auf Service und Support
Und dann gehen wir hier
Ich meine es gibt wirklich Leute die das noch fragen
Treiber und Hilfsprogramme
Und das erste wo man hingeht ist doch
Google
Produktnummer
Treiber
Oder irgendwie sowas
Wir legen hier unser Betriebssystem aus
Wenn wir jetzt Windows 10 haben
Und es keine Treiber
Keine passenden Treiber gibt
Dann nehmen wir einfach das nächste was drunter ist
BIOS
Google ist zu schwer
Ich sehe es schon
Theoretisch
Und
Das brauchen wir auch nicht
Schauen wir mal ob es für Windows 7 vernünftige Treiber gibt
Audio
LAN
Alles da
Das ist ja schon mal richtig
Und hier laden wir dann alles einzeln runter
Die BIOS Version brauchen wir erst
Ja willkommen in der Windows Welt
Unter Linux wird es jetzt mal eine Runde
Ich sag mal stellvertretend Upgrade machen
Und es wäre alles aktualisiert
Aber
Nicht so unter Windows
Nicht
Wer jetzt Treiber für seine AMD oder ATI Grafik hat
Sucht geht auf die Seite von AMD.com
Geht hier oben auf Treiber und Support
Verwendet dann entweder das automatische Erkennen und Installieren
Zeugs was die anbieten
Oder sucht sich hier passend seine Karte raus
Gehen wir zu Graphics oder Professional Graphics
Da muss man sich einfach mal durchklicken
Und
Schließlich habe ich hier unter dem
Legacy Graphics
Radeon X war es glaube ich gewesen
Okay das Ding ist wirklich schon ein bisschen älter
Rausgesucht
Und das installiert ihr jetzt auch gerade
Fertigstellen
Und dann können wir neu starten
Schade
Interessante Frage
Aventador fragt
Findest du 1.000 Euro PC RTX 3060 TI
Ryzen 5 3600 für einen 13-jährigen kleinen Bruder
Too much
Man kann nie too much PC haben
Wenn du die Kohle hast
Xeon ist drin
Und
Ja
275 Punkte haben wir gekriegt
Ich musste nichts weitermachen
Als einfach die CPU zu ersetzen
Da muss noch neue Wärmeleitpaste drauf
Da ist nämlich nur noch die andere Hälfte
Von dem Mist hier drauf
Das ist der 1,8 GHz
Moment hat er jetzt den Xeon schon drauf?
Ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst
2 Duo
Ja 265 Cinebench Punkte sind definitiv nicht super duper
Hat er den Xeon jetzt schon drauf gehabt?
Oder ist es noch der alte?
Wartet
Und ich habe eine andere Windows Installation genommen
Hier von der SSD
Weil
Ich nämlich gemerkt habe
Dass ich eine 32 Bit Version installiert habe
Ich habe jetzt den Arbeitsspeicher angeguckt
Äh nur 4,5
32 Bit
Ah los
Paint Champ
Ja
Scheint so als hätte ich den Stick
On purpose
So
Konfiguriert
Hier das Ding wo
Windows 7 drauf steht
Ja
Benutze ich das Ding mal ein bisschen
Und werde euch dann meine Erfahrungen mitteilen
Was damit so alles geht
Ne?
Ich würde mal sagen
Wir beginnen jetzt einfach mal mit Minecraft
Gut
Und wie man hier sehen kann
Man würde ja eigentlich davon ausgehen
Minecraft läuft überall drauf
Aber Minecraft darf man immer noch nicht vergessen
Vor allem die
Die Version die hauptsächlich verändert
Ist irgendwie so ein Java Gedöns
Und das ist halt aus Prinzip lahm
Ein paar Spielen
Ja
Ich darf nicht so sehr über Java flamen
Weil
Java an sich
Ähm
Eigentlich gar nichts schlechtes ist
Java ist weder bloated noch lahm
Noch sonst was
Das einzige Problem ist
Dass die meisten Anwendungen sacken
Aber da kann Java nichts für
Und es ist RTX Off
Aber wenn ihr was ausprobieren würdet
Was überall drauf läuft
Dann könnt ihr einfach mal CSGO installieren
CSGO ist so ein guter Filter
Also wenn CSGO nicht läuft
Weiß man
Der PC ist schon mal Instant Schrott
Wohl ganz in Ordnung
Sag ich jetzt mal
Es gibt hier und da so ein paar kleine Ruckler
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung
Low FPS aber
Vollkommen in Ordnung
Da kann man das ganz gut spielen
Kannste wahrscheinlich wieder als 0 Euro Minecraft PC anbieten oder so
Zudem ist mir aufgefallen
Das bei diesem Spiel
Der Grafikkartenlüfter so alle 10 Minuten
Mal für eine halbe Minute aufgeheult ist
Doch ältere Grafikkarten
Die haben nur so Lüfterstufen so
Idle
Laut und sehr gut
Vollpulle
Ja
Ich habe auch vorgehabt
Noch ein paar andere Spiele zu testen
Aber ich habe mal den Valley Benchmark installiert
Das probiere ich ja immer mal gerne aus
Wenn man da allerdings mit DirectX 11 ein Spiel testen möchte
Dann wird das nichts
Weil die Karte kein DirectX 11 oder 10 unterstützt
Und unter DirectX 9 haben wir da irgendwie 5 oder 6 FPS
Auf 720p im Low Preset
Also
Spielen wird man hiermit eigentlich sonst nicht mehr können
Vielleicht Cuphead oder so
Der macht aber das meiste glaube ich eher die CPU
Käme man jetzt auf die Idee
Das als Office PC zu deklarieren
Ja gut der Mist funktioniert ja überall
Kannste damit wohl machen
Also ich sage immer bei total alten oder schlechten Laptops
Ja da kannst du ein Buch mit schreiben
Geht hier auf jeden Fall ganz gut mit
Ne sehen wir ja hier
Mein wunderschöner Tagebucheintrag
Vom 22.22.2022
Sollte man nun auf die Idee kommen
Mit einem Office PC bei Ebay kleidern
Also Browsersurfen braucht mehr Rechenleistung als man denkt
Ich würde sagen Neberspielen
Ist mittlerweile
Ist Internet Surfen tatsächlich
Die zweit leistungshungrige Sachen
Was viele Leute jeden Tag an ihrem PC machen
Weil du hast nicht nur ein Tab auf
Du hast keine Ahnung 30 Tabs auf
Du spielst damit Videos ab
Du machst im Zweifelsfall vielleicht irgendwelche online
Was weiß ich
Agar.io oder was auch immer
Also Browser zieht
Also erstens fressen Browser RAM ohne Ende
Und wenn ihr mal guckt
Im Task Manager oder Prozessor Explorer
Die Dinger verbrauchen auch recht ordentlich CPU Last
Gar nicht mal so
Das Internet Browsen jetzt
Nichts brauchen würde
Irgendetwas zu suchen
Klappt das schon ganz gut
Auf jeden Fall sehr viel besser als bei diesem Surface RT Laptop
Oder Tablet
Zu dem ich letztens mal ein Video gemacht habe
Die Seiten brauchen ein bisschen zum laden
Werbung ist dabei also würde man einen Adblocker verwenden
Macht das vor allem bei älteren PCs Sinn
Dass die Seiten dann vielleicht ein bisschen schneller aufrufen
Besuchen wir dann einmal die Seite der Bild
Dauert es so lange die Seite aufzurufen
Ich habe mir mal sagen lassen
Dass die Seite etwas anspruchsvoller ist
Wenn sie geladen werden soll
Und dann noch eine Sache
Die mich tatsächlich sehr überrascht hat
Bei YouTube
Das ist so schlimm
Dieses Anmelde Popup
Das nervt mich extrem
Geht mir so auf den Keks
Bei YouTube
Ich habe mir da ein Video gemacht
Früher konntest du im Browser gar keinen Tab aufmachen
In Full HD
Mit 50 FPS
Und das klappt tatsächlich
Wahrscheinlich
Weil die Grafikkarte trotzdem noch ein bisschen was übernimmt
Videodecoder hatten die alten Grafikkarten nicht
Aber zumindest für die Grafikausgabe
Grafikkarte von 2006
Aber auch da würde ich sagen
Macht das meiste wirklich die CPU
Auf jeden Fall
Also das Decoding macht auf jeden Fall die CPU
Und so was drauf
Weiß ich nicht
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht
Dazu muss ich noch sagen
Dass ich den HDMI Ausgang
Vom DVI Adapter
Mit meiner Capture Karte nicht aufzeichnen konnte
Deswegen ich das jetzt auch vom Monitor
Hier abfilme
Da ist ein guter Gesellschafter
Bauer filmt auch immer vom Monitor ab
Pass mal auf
Man guckt ein Video von mir an
Und rechts sind nur Videos von mir
Und was würdet ihr sagen
Naja
Also gelohnt hat es sich definitiv nicht
Meiner Meinung nach
Der ist total viel rumgefahren
Und es hat ewig gedauert
Also dann lieber ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nehmen
Und halt für ein Appel und ein Ei
Einen gebrauchten PC kaufen
Aber als Experiment finde ich es eine coole Sache
Ziemlich nice Video
Die Kiste läuft nicht stabil
Keine Ahnung
Ist die Frage
So wie lange sind wir schon on?
Ich krieg so langsam Hunger
Wir haben noch 30 Milliarden Videos zu gucken
Aber die werden wir heute nicht alle gucken
Games in Oktober
Das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren
Was jetzt demnächst raus kommt
Ob da irgendwas gescheites dabei ist
Mal kurz drüber skippen
Was kommt denn neues raus
Shadowlands stimmt
Ja aber wow
Juckt mich nicht
Cyberpunk kommt irgendwann
Wann kommt dann Cyberpunk?
Muss doch irgendwann auch mal demnächst an
Welche Youtuber kannst du zum Thema Programmieren Linux ETC empfehlen?
Boah
Tutorials die ich immer ganz gerne gucke
Ach du Scheiße wie heißen die?
Ich kann das immer nicht richtig schreiben
Die gucke ich ganz gerne
Ich kann mir die immer merken
Weil der auch Max heißt
Die gucke ich eigentlich ganz gerne als Tutorials
Ansonsten schaue ich ehrlich gesagt
Immer rum über die Youtube Suche
Was aktuell gerade mich interessiert
Und was da zu einer was macht
Also für Microcontrollergedöns
Gucke ich ihn hier noch gerne aus der Schweiz
Der macht auch gute Videos
Jo
Ansonsten müsste ich mal ein bisschen
Tiefer Gedanken drüber machen
19. November ok
18. November ok
Er
Okay
Es ist irgendwie
Nichts
Nichts dabei, was mich juckt
Fall Guys Season 2
Ja, Seasons zu machen ist ja
Spätestens ein Fortnite voll im Trend
Und das
Fall Guys und Fortnite Community
Sich irgendwie überschneiden, habe ich den Eindruck
Machen die auch Seasons und passt
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe
Fall Guys auch nicht gespielt, aber ich finde die Optik
Echt niedlich
So, was haben wir sonst noch
AliExpress cooler
Bestimmt langweilig, die letzten Dinos Tech Tips Videos
Waren alle nicht so spannend
Wasser gekühlt, Geldautomaten
Gehackt werden
Wie werden denn Geldautomaten gehackt
Hackermans
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
2010 hält der Sicherheitsforscher Barnaby Jack
Einen legendären Vortrag auf einer
Hackerkonferenz
Ich mache das immer fertig, dass der sich ähnlich anhört wie
Willi Pietkast
Damals sagt er
Geldautomaten sind ein attraktives Ziel
Also das bietet sich an, dass im Geldautomaten Geld ist
Ja für Verbrecher, weil sie naja voller Geld sind
Deshalb gibt es einen Haufen Leute, die immer wieder versuchen, sie aufzusprengen
Andere das gab es in Frankfurt auch in Frankfurt gab es vor
Das ist auch gar nicht so lange her
Da gab es irgendwelche Typen, die haben die, die haben versucht, aus der Wand zu reißen
Wahrscheinlich haben sie das in ein Auto gebunden, sind losgefahren oder so
Ja, versuchen sogar gleich den ganzen Automaten
Ja, ja, sowas, sowas
All das sind sehr
Das haben die versucht, aus der Wand zu reißen
Laute, eher unelegante Verbrechen
Wie viel cooler wäre es, wenn man einfach seinen Laptop anschließen könnte
Und ein paar Keyboard Sounds später spuckt der Automat Geld aus
So wie in Terminator 2
Easy money, come on
Easy
Da steckt tatsächlich eine gewisse Wahrheit
Geldautomaten sind im Grunde Computer
Computer, die man mit Windows XP zum größten Teil hacken kann
Heute geht es um gigantische Banküberfälle
Um internationale Verbrecherorganisationen
Und um Software aus dem Darknet, mit der jeder Amateur einen Automaten Geld stecken lassen kann
Meine Control-Taste ist schon wieder abgegangen, ich bekomme Anfälle, diese Kapp-Tastatur
Erstmal
Auch in Deutschland
Willkommen in der Welt des Jackpots
Das was?
Ein Geldautomat besteht im Prinzip aus zwei Teilen
Der untere Teil ist abgesichert und verstärkt, quasi der Safe
Dieser Teil nennt sich Dispenser
Im Dispenser sind meist vier bis sechs Geldkassetten mit jeweils verschiedenen Geldscheinen
Darüber sitzt die Topbox
Darin befinden sich zum Beispiel ein Drucker für Quittungen, eine Kamera und ein eingebauter, speziell konfigurierter Computer
Der ist in der Regel per USB mit dem Dispenser verbunden
Dazu kommt zum Beispiel über ein Ethernet-Kabel oder einen Router eine Verbindung mit dem Netzwerk der jeweiligen Bank
Geldautomaten kann man auf unterschiedliche Arten hacken
Häufig greift man den physischen Automaten selbst an
Allgemein sind hier freistehende Exemplare in Kiosks oder so besonders attraktiv
Aber auch eingebettete Varianten sind angreifbar
Teilweise gibt es einfach einen Generalschlüssel, um die Topboxes von bestimmten Automaten zu öffnen
Solche Schlüssel kann man im Darknet oder sogar auf Alibaba kaufen
Man kann sich einen Generalschlüssel für einen Geldautomat bei Aliexpress kaufen?
In anderen Fällen müssen die Diebe die Topbox auch mit Gewalt aufbrechen
Die ist im Gegensatz zum Dispenser in vielen Gründen nicht aufgesehen
Also Leute, Leute
Das ist nur ein getarnter Regenschirm oder?
Das Ding ist doch bestimmt nur getarnter
Also wenn das ein echter Regenschirm ist
Da hättet ihr euch mal besser drauf vorbereitet, wenn ihr euch das mal anschauen wollt
Also wenn das ein echter Regenschirm ist, dann hättet ihr euch mal besser darauf vorbereitet, wenn ihr das mal anschauen wollt
Also wenn das ein echter Regenschirm ist, dann hättet ihr euch mal besser drauf vorbereitet, wenn ihr euch das mal anschauen wollt
Und wenigstens mal ein Brecheisen mitnehmen, anstatt den Regenschirm
In vielen Fällen nur schwach gesichert, das ist häufig also sehr easy
Manchmal nutzen Verbrecher auch ein Endoskop, um bestimmte Stellen auswendig zu machen und präzise Löcher zu bohren
Hat man sich auf irgendeine Weise Zugang zu den Geräten innerhalb der Topbox verschafft, gibt es wieder verschiedene Optionen
Der Angriff kann je nach Hersteller, Betriebssystem des Automaten und Hacking-Methode etwas anders aussehen
Allgemein ist es häufig überraschend einfach, einen Geldautomaten zu hacken
Die Software ist recht standardisiert und oft ultra-alt und nicht up-to-date
Einige Automaten laufen noch mit Windows XP, andere mit Vista, Windows 7 oder 8
Außerdem treffen viele Betreiber häufig einfach keine entsprechenden Schutzmaßnahmen
Das ist besonders interessant, wenn man bedenkt, dass manche Geldautomaten
200.000 bis 450.000 Euro enthalten können, je nachdem, wo sie stehen
Wenn die RMV-Ticket-Automaten laufen mit einem Raspberry Pi und Raspbian drauf, kommt man an das Geld
Mal wird ein USB-Stick mit Schadsoftware in den Computer innerhalb der Topbox gesteckt
In anderen Fällen ist es ein Handy mit einem Kabel oder ein Laptop
Das Ziel ist hier immer, den Computer zu infizieren und unter Kontrolle zu bringen
Teils wird auch ein eigenes Gerät, Blackbox genannt, direkt an den Desktops gesteckt
Die Blackbox gibt sich dann als der interne Computer aus
Sobald eins davon gelingt, befiehlt der Dieb, dem infizierten PC oder der Blackbox per Tastatur oder auch SMS-Codes Geld auszuwerfen
Die Befehle werden an den Deskpenser weitergeleitet und...
Jackpot
Ah, yes
Barnaby Jack hat das Thema vor rund 10 Jahren mit seinem Vortrag auf der DEFCON berühmt gemacht
Seitdem ist Jackpotting zu einem boomenden Geschäft geworden
Mit etwa 20 Sorten entsprechender Schadsoftware im Umlauf
Einige der Varianten kann man tatsächlich einfach im Darknet kaufen
Teils sind diese Programme so einfach zu nutzen, dass sie sogar etwas verspielt sind
Da wäre zum Beispiel der Cutlet Maker aus Russland
Ein Kotlet ist russischer Slang für ein Bündel Geld
Beim Nachfolger Winpot klickt man einfach auf Spin und gewinnt jedes Mal den Jackpot
Verbrecher in Südamerika, den USA, Russland und auch Europa erbeuten mit Jackpotting Angriffen
Immer wieder gewaltige Summen Bargeld
Eine Gruppe war in den letzten Jahren auch in Deutschland aktiv und hat...
Die machen aber nichts dagegen, weil es glaube ich nicht genug Leute versuchen und wahrscheinlich oft genug erwischt werden
Das ist so ein...
Also wahrscheinlich geht das so lange, weil die nicht genug leiden drunter
Wisst ihr, wenn das nur ein paar Leute machen und die meisten davon dann auch erwischt werden
Dann interessiert die das nicht großartig, dann gibt es keinen Grund das zu verbessern
Wenn es jetzt jeder zweite...
Machen würde und keiner wird erwischt, dann haben sie ein Problem
Allein in NRW in zehn Fällen insgesamt mehr als 1,4 Millionen Euro erbeutet
Das ist zwar ziemlich viel Geld, aber es gibt noch eine andere Variante des Jackpottings
Und die ist noch viel gefährlicher
Es gibt kriminelle Gruppen, die die Netzwerke gesamter Banken attackieren
Bei diesen Angriffen schicken die Hacker Mitarbeitern der jeweiligen Bank zunächst E-Mails mit bestimmten Anhängen
Werden diese infizierten Anhänge geöffnet...
...die Hacker Zugang zum PC des jeweiligen Mitarbeiters
Von dort infiltrieren sie nach und nach das Netzwerk, bis sie zu wichtigen PCs und Servern vordringen
Das können Computer sein, auf denen finanzielle Transaktionen kontrolliert und getätigt werden
Oder Server, von denen aus die Geldautomaten der Bank mit Updates versorgt werden
Über solche Server werden die gesamten Geldautomaten...
Ich meine, es ist ganz schön fail, dass das so ohne weiteres möglich ist
Wahrscheinlich läuft das auch auf Windows XP
...einer Bank infiziert und können dann quasi ferngesteuert werden
...und können dann quasi ferngesteuert werden
Im nächsten Schritt schicken die Hacker Moneymules quasi Laufburschen los, um zu bestimmten Zeiten vor bestimmten Automaten zu stehen
Letztere spucken dann wie magisch einfach Geld aus
Die Kriminellen verschicken außerdem riesige Summen von der Bank ins Ausland oder blasen Accounts künstlich auf, die dann von anderen Laufburschen geleert werden
riesige Summen von der Bank ins Ausland oder blasen Accounts künstlich auf,
die dann von anderen Laufburschen geleert werden.
Ein berühmtes Beispiel ist hier die Carbana-Gruppe, die ab 2013 aktiv wurde
und der gewissermaßen größte Banküberfall aller Zeiten.
Diese Geschichte ist aber so vielschichtig, dass wir sie gerne in einem anderen Video erzählen wollen.
Auch Nordkorea versucht, die Wiener Banken systematisch zu infiltrieren und dann auszurauben.
Fast-Cash-Netzwerkangriffe sind nach Informationen des FBIs auf die Beagle Boys-Gruppe zurückzuführen.
Die klingen irgendwie witzig, sind aber ein Teil der Hacker-Fraktion des nordkoreanischen Militärs.
Sowohl gegen physische als auch gegen netzwerkbasierte Angriffe
gibt es viele Schutzmöglichkeiten für Banken und Betreiber von Geldautomaten.
Die Angriffe sind keineswegs neu, die Lösungen auch nicht.
Was man daran wieder sieht...
Big Brain?
Big Brain siegt über Low Brain.
Der Typ, der mit der Pistole in die Bank rennt und irgendwie mit 40.000 Euro wieder raus rennt,
höchstwahrscheinlich erwischt wird und danach erstmal aus dem Verkehr gezogen wird,
hat die Arschkarte.
Die Typen, die Big Brain-Remote-Hackermans machen und Geld abgreifen und wahrscheinlich nicht erwischt werden,
machen die dicke Kohle und haben danach halt die Kohle.
Es gibt unzählige Geldautomaten und häufig wäre es wahrscheinlich sehr teuer,
alle im Nachhinein abzugreifen.
Da lässt man es teils wohl einfach drauf ankommen.
Viele kleine Geldautomaten gehören zu irgendwelchen Kiosks und Einkaufszentren
und die Verantwortlichen haben derartige Angriffe vielleicht auch einfach nicht auf dem Schirm.
So oder so ist es irgendwie schockierend, wie einfach es sein kann,
mit etwas Software auf dem Darknet bis zu 450.000 Euro zu erbeuten.
Wenn die wüssten, was im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld da an riesigen Sicherheitsglücken offenstehen und nur noch keiner gefunden hat.
Und solange einige Geldautomaten nicht auf dem Schirm stehen, können sie nicht auf dem Schirm gehen.
Und solange einige Geldautomaten tatsächlich noch Windows XP nutzen,
heißt es für die Diebe bis auf weiteres wohl einfach...
Come on, let's go spend some money.
Ja, cheers.
Excellent.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
Was hat man sonst noch zu bieten? Ich hab übelst Hunger, so langsam aber sicher.
Wieder drei Stunden on.
So, was kann man uns noch angucken?
Wer... und das hat... Moment, haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Das haben wir doch als allererstes geguckt heute.
Huge update.
Oh, so...
Home-Server-Video.
Excellent.
Das... das muss sein.
Ja.
So.
Das ist wieder was, wo ich mir gleich am Anfang denke,
was hat er bitteschön daheim alles für Dinger?
Also, was hat er für Stromverbrauch?
Wie kühlt er das Ganze, weil das wird heiß?
Wo hat er das eingebaut, weil es ist laut?
Ähm...
Das sind ein bisschen... ein Tick modernere Sachen, als das das letzte Mal.
Er hat wieder ein recht ordentliches Rack.
Sogar mit diesen Besen-Dingern. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die offiziell heißen.
Ist das der Däne? Keine Ahnung.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Nee, das ist nicht der Däne.
Der Däne hatten wir das letzte Mal.
Alter, geht das noch leiser?
Okay, man versteht ihn nicht.
Vergiss... man versteht ihn nicht. Ich laber da jetzt einfach drüber.
Du verstehst null.
Also, erstens, man versteht ihn nicht und außerdem verstehst du,
auch wenn du ihn verstehen würdest nicht, was er sagt.
Also, was hat er denn am Start hier?
Okay.
Ah!
Okay, das sieht ganz, ganz gut aus.
Das sind eindeutig die neueren Teile von ihm.
Was ist das?
Cisco, was? Web Security Appliance. Irgend so eine ASA oder sowas, hä?
Was ist denn das?
Eine WSA, keine ASA, eine WSA.
Ich weiß nicht, was das Ding macht.
Dann stinken nochmal alle 48 Port Switches.
Ein Keystone Panel.
Die ultra praktisch sind, diese Dinger übrigens.
Da gibt's...
Also, ich find die praktischer als ein Patch Panel, weil du kannst hier unterschiedliche Sachen reinmachen.
Du kannst Netzwerk...
Ähm...
Also, R45 Stecker reinklipsen, USB reinklipsen, SFP reinklipsen.
SFP Plus.
Der hat aber ordentlich aufgerüstet bei sich daheim.
Das ist doch wirklich nett.
Oh, ne?
Warum ist...
Warum ist denn ein HDMI an nem...
Switch?
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Hat irgendjemand von euch nen Plan, warum es nen Switch mit HDMI gibt?
Äh, baust du dir jetzt ein eigenes XP, nachdem der Source Code gelegt wurde?
Stimmt, das könnten wir uns auch mal angucken.
HDMI Stacking.
Ähm, das heißt, man kann die Switche über HDMI verbinden miteinander.
Also, man macht dann keine, äh, Glasfaser-Dinger-Verbindung mehr von Switch zu Switch.
Sondern, ähm, man macht, weil HDMI viel Bandbreite hat oder wie, man verbindet dann die Switche miteinander.
Das ist eigentlich ne ziemlich clevere Idee.
Alle mal besser, dass du dir da zwei Module kaufen musst.
Einfach HDMI und cooles.
Okay...
Das sind, das sind...
Das ist schwierig zu erkennen, wenn er so nah dran ist.
Sind das 2...
Sind das 2,5 oder 3,5 Zoll Platten?
Ich würd sagen 2,5.
Okay, das ist...
Aha, wusste ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass HDMI Stacking ein Ding ist.
Aber wenn du es jetzt so sagst, wenn es Probleme macht, okay.
Wobei die meisten Sachen, die die anbieten, eigentlich immer ziemlich gut funktionieren.
Also, wenn...
Die haben ja so den Hang dazu, die bieten 15 Jahre lang das Gleiche an.
Und wenn sie dann was Neues anbieten, dann funktioniert es meistens auch ganz gut.
Also im Netzwerk, Netzwerksegment, die Dinger sind meistens ziemlich stabil.
Aber ich hab damit gar keine Erfahrung, also mit HDMI.
Von Switch zu Switch.
Okay, das ist ein ESX-Server.
Warum hat der denn so viel Zeugs wieder daheim?
Was zum Geier...
Was mach...
Was machen die alle?
Und ich sag schon, dass das hier Overkill war.
Guck mal, ich...
Und ich bin schon der Meinung, das hier ist Overkill.
Bei mir.
Die 4AE-Kiste mach ich nicht.
Das ist...
Die 4AE-Kiste macht ja auch gar nichts mehr.
Sogar das ist schon Overkill.
Und dann kommen die anderen an, haben einen Full-Size-Rack voll.
Zwei.
Zwei Full-Size-Rack voll.
Äh, ne Moment, wo sind wir denn hier?
The fuck?
Warum hat das eigentlich so viel negative Bewertung?
Was hat das denn...
Oder was heißt so viel?
Ist es ja gar nicht.
Aber was fanden die Leute denn nicht gut an dem Video?
Da ist...
Bestimmt irgendwelche Wichtigtour wieder.
Ja, ja.
Okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Solche Spezialleute hast du immer.
Braucht man das wirklich?
Nö.
Hahaha.
Exzellent Antwort, Max.
Perfekt.
Hahaha.
Braucht man das wirklich?
Nein, braucht man nicht.
Deshalb 227 Speicher belegt.
Immerhin ist das Video öffentlich.
Ja.
Alter, wenn du schon am Meckern bist, wenn die Leute schon am Meckern sind, müssen sie sich das auch mal richtig angucken.
Natürlich ist der Server per 10 Gigabit am Switch angeschlossen.
Was nicht per 10 Gigabit angeschlossen ist, ist mein Desktop.
Oder das stimmt, also zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Hä, okay, manche Leute muss man nicht verstehen.
Der Server, ja.
Threehead, ja.
Lowbrain.
Okay, es leuchtet mir absolut nicht ein.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor, was der, was der sonst noch alles...
What the f...
Was machen die Leute daheim?
BTF?
Das ist voller als ein Rack bei uns im Rechenzentrum.
Okay, und das sind irgendwelche ollen...
Was ist das?
Irgendeine olle Sassplatte oder so.
Irgendwas, was wahrscheinlich einfach nur laut ist, viel Strom verbraucht und kaum Speicherplatz hat.
Was, es muss alles über den Router?
What?
Warum?
Moment, das ist das zweite Rack jetzt.
Alter, was ist mit den Leuten?
Moment, wie viele, wie viel Terabyte waren das gerade?
Moment, Moment, ich hab hier...
Warte mal.
Drei?
Okay, der hat allein schon hier, also eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, dreizehn, vierzehn.
Wahrscheinlich vier.
Vierzehn, oder so.
Äh, vierzehn, vierzehn mal drei, Big Brain.
Quick Maths, was ist...
Leute, vierzehn, was ist vierzehn mal drei?
Äh...
Äh, was ist, was ist vierzehn mal drei?
Dreißig.
Vier mal drei, zwölf, zweiundvierzig.
Excellent, zweiundvierzig Terabyte, ordentlich.
Quick Maths, ja.
Die Antwort auf alles.
Okay.
SFP plus.
What?
Also jetzt ist er dahinter, jetzt ist er dahinter.
Gut.
Also...
Jetzt hat er noch eine Mini, eine Mini-Rack daneben stehen.
Das war zu wenig.
Leute, es ist eindeutig zu wenig gemessen.
Ja, da brauchst du schon wieder Heimnetz.
Okay, ich, ich, ich finde ja, solche Setups sind nicht so gut.
immer cool.
Was mich immer viel mehr interessiert
ist, was genau machen
die damit? Weil, wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon
Schwierigkeiten gehabt, meine 4 HE-Kiste
irgendwie sinnvoll zu verwenden daheim.
Und da denke ich mir so, ey,
was machen die
damit? Also, keine Ahnung.
Es muss ja schon irgendwie was
halbwegs Sinnvolles sein.
Sonst würde man das
wahrscheinlich auf Dauer nicht machen.
Also irgendwas
davon haben muss man ja.
Cheat 95, ja, im letzten
Video haben wir auch einen gesehen, der hatte Playcenter
am Start.
Es ist schon geil, sowas zu haben, aber
was macht man damit genau?
Ich habe ja schon Schwierigkeiten
jetzt, neben diesen
6, 7 Sachen, die ich hier daheim
verwende, dass mir da noch
weitere Services einfallen,
die sinnvoll wären für mich daheim.
Ich habe da
meinen Fileserver laufen, ich habe meinen Wiki laufen,
ich habe meinen Nextcloud laufen,
mein Telefon, mein Sync-Gedöns,
ja, so ein paar
Kleingraben-Sachen, ja,
letzten End-Crip-Zertifikate,
mein Git-Frontend,
aber ansonsten, mir fällt da gar nicht so viel
ein, was ich noch sinnvollerweise
überhaupt machen könnte.
Aber warum nicht?
Das haben wir uns schon mal
angeguckt, das kenne ich, das haben wir glaube ich schon mal
gesehen.
Die Support-Dudes, ja, ja, das haben wir
schon gesehen.
Es könnte auch sein, dass die in einem anderen Land,
wo der Strom viel billiger ist,
das ist auch möglich.
Data Center Project,
okay, der versucht einfach, so viel
wie möglich
bei sich daheim einzubauen.
Guck mal, es ist ein bisschen weniger geworden
bei ihm daheim.
So,
oder es ist jetzt noch was
zusätzliches, was er hat.
Was hat er hier?
6 Gigabit SAS,
1,6T. Alter, was der Scheiß
für Abwärme produziert, Strom kostet
und nix bringt oder im Strich,
Wahnsinn.
Aber Moment, das ist eine SSD?
Habe ich mir jetzt
verguckt, ist das eine SSD?
Ist das eine SSD?
Das ist eine SSD!
Okay,
okay, dann,
dann alles zurück, weil ich gesagt habe,
ich dachte, das wäre eine Platte.
Ich dachte, das wäre eine Platte.
Ach, das ist eine SSD, ja, dann ist es nicht,
dann ist das tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Nein, ich habe noch nichts über den XP-Leak gesagt,
weil ich mir den XP-Leak
euch angeguckt habe.
My server exploded, okay,
das müssen wir uns auch noch angucken.
Langweilig.
Eins muss man ja sagen, recht ordentlich gemacht hat das.
Everything else,
okay, warum, warum ist das Server exploded?
Zeig her.
Können die sich, könnten die, könnten die sich vielleicht mal ein Mikrofon anhängen?
Wie soll man denn, wie soll man denn da was verstehen?
Hört euch das an?
Today's video is sponsored by IBM.
Ist doch nicht euer Ernst?
Was ist das für Audioqualität?
Ne, das haben wir noch nicht gesehen.
Ähm.
As many of you suggested the, the vaulted selection.
Ah.
The vaulted selection.
The vaulted selector was set wrong and that is why it let out all of the smoke.
Ah.
It might then.
Aha.
Come from the US and has just never been in use over here,
because I have not changed this.
Otherwise it would have to have.
Haben die in Dänemark nicht auch 230 Volt?
Of this.
It's a bit more flimsy.
Oh, guck mal, ein Anti-Static-Ding.
Very scary business, but these riser cars are not very expensive.
So, if you should break this card, it's only a matter of 30 Dollars or something.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ähm, so, ich werde mir den gerade mal speichern.
Ich sehe das immer im Nachhinein.
Ich sehe ja, ich sehe ja, wann Clips angelegt werden und eine sehr beliebte Sache ist, jedes
Mal, wo fast jedes Mal ein Clip angelegt wird, wenn ich zeige, wie man mehrere Tabs bookmarkt
ohne Add-on.
Das, das finden die Leute immer ultra spannend anscheinend.
So, 27.9.
Excellent.
Gleich mal gucken.
Jetzt haben wir alle Tabs von heute da.
100 Clips incoming.
Ja, das ist jedes Mal ein Bookmark, das ist mindestens einer, wenn ich die Sachen, äh,
die Bookmarks.
Virtualization Homelab Guide.
Ne, wir gucken uns das nächstes Mal an.
Excellent.
Oh.
So, wir haben das hier.
Ah, wir haben das hier.
Ich hab hier ein bisschen was eingebaut.
Das ist, das ist, äh, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Die Farbe für seine Router oder was auch immer das ist.
Wenn der irgendein Mikro tickt, singen sie 1, 12 von den, keine Ahnung, was ist das?
Ne, ist es nicht.
Ah, ich weiß, was es ist.
Ich glaub, das ist so eine fertige PFSense, äh, äh, Kiste, die man sich kaufen kann.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, sag ich doch, PFSense.
Nächste, hier, Predicted hat er es.
Das ist so ein fertiges PFSense-Kabel, das ist so ein PFSense-Kabel.
oder auch nicht
ja, sag ich doch, pfSense
wisst ihr, hier
predicted hat das
dass das so ein fertiges pfSense Ding ist
excellent
so Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen
gibt's schon WiFi 6
ich glaub der Standard ist immer noch nicht raus
aber die Hersteller bauen schon irgendwelche Drafts ein
das ist aber mal
ein super ordentliches Rack
guck mal, sogar mit Leuchtröhre
drin und sowas
das ist eines der, ok, dieses Rack
haben die nur gebaut, um es zu zeigen
in einem Video
so sehen einfach keine Racks aus, die mit dem Einsatz sind
exposed
das ist ultra
ordentlich, guck mal, sogar hier die unterschiedlichen Farben
und so
das ist ein Show Rack
ah ok, das passt, so sieht's auch aus
ja, diese Keystone Dinger, wie gesagt, die sind echt gut
ok, jetzt können wir uns das nächste Mal angucken
ähm
ähm, ähm, ähm
so, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen
äh, geh fort, Desktop
warum ist es nicht mehr transparent, wenn ich weiter ran zoome
was ist, was ist das?
was ist das?
was ist mit Windows hier wieder los?
ok, man muss es nicht versuchen zu verstehen
alles klar, Leute, ich hab übelst Hunger
ich geh jetzt was essen
vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Nachmittag
wir müssen nämlich den Webserver weiterprogrammieren
findet man Zeit
haben wir schon eine Woche lang nicht weiter gemacht
wir sehen uns, bis denn, macht's gut
CU, ich geh was essen
bis denn
blblblblblblblblblblblblblbl